yeah exactly don't forget this is one of
the this is one of the characters that
was the the starting starting point of
discussion for this whole
france versus usa rivalry
vegeto has never been a bad character
guys
he just chucked him twice
but there we go snatching them at the
sky level three on the way and now
cloudy is all up to the ui this could be
the first victory for france it's got
five bars
the opportunity is there you gotta play
clean cloud yes same with your chest
cloud use the combo knights will taught
me that one reach out
oh you can actually
kill oh he's actually dead he might be
dead it might be enough listen
like i'm supposed to be here for france
but
brown but we've got that android 17 in
here for yasha final character for both
these guys what's it going to be
feathers
so tense right now you can see the nooch
oh he tried it
challenged though
it might be
watch out watch out watch out watch out
[Music]
reminding us why he's here
very very he's just a content creator
twitch chat he's just a content creator
man
i never put any kind of doubt on my
man's clouds uh but we're going
one-on-one here first game of
tons of games guys you're gonna lose to
this guy you've been counting on you're
gonna lose to
him oh look we got oh no no no coaching
no coaching hey come on get some rules
get out of here
coaching is allowed never mind follow
the rules yeah come on bro follow the
rules
everybody gets one everybody gets one
okay okay
oh nice for flex
back into it this is so tense this is
how we want to start
nice blocks
that was so sick
candy ball
let's drop the combo
or the larry article
situation
[Applause]
there we go he got mixed gogeta blue
right here going to work right now
that could move you gotta block this out
nice raw tag after the reflect very good
stuff that's classic americana
that's so clean yeah opened up with the
jab and yasha right now gonna get this
full corner combo
shiela combo with kojita blue
yeah i think that that like
even though cloud's team is obviously
not built around getting levels he's
just using gojira as you know just for
his tools
it's still worth killing this fight
because
nice and yasha will not tech because he
knows oh this time cloud goes straight
for the knockdown
oh you gotta hold this uh spark you
didn't want to take the mix at all oh
you got all this pressure this is scary
ah
i can open you up i just gotta hit you
mid knock on the door ah
this is a really good situation for
cloud actually because it's hot it's all
gone
number one level three i think he brings
me
yeah i think ui gets the better pressure
off them right yes yeah and it helped
your character he's trying to be as as
smart as possible with the health
management right here i really like that
from cloud and this is an even game
okay let's see yasha here on the defense
box oh he's waiting for the assist cool
down he's gonna get a 50 50 here you got
to hold this yep
bring it back
bring it back get off the screen the
superior gogeta he's here to play clown
805
okay that's one down
all right here we go
your silly vegito is not strong enough
and you know he is comfortable just
playing in this mutual game
yeah something about yasha's he's always
comfortable using all the time you can't
ban it you can't escape from america the
supremacy he's coming in cloud
continuing to shine you may have beat
him in the 16-man bracket but today he's
here to play oh boy is he ever okay
android 17 note does not convey combo
nervous yeah you can see it yasha this
is a team that i don't normally see him
play that much of his main team the team
gohan team is always the one that i see
yasha played by i don't know he's trying
something different here
he's gone he went straight through
that's good that's good good stuff
and he's gonna get this cool combo bring
him towards the corner with that level
three knocked down here no spark for
either player so it's on his games
to challenge with the 2l but no
he might be dead
he's going to take a lot the probation
is really bad on this combo
oh i was enough even game
clowns can still fight back clown can
still fight back who is gone though so
mix isn't going to be as potent here
super nash
[Applause]
what an assist bro that is
cloud it is all up to that gogeta four
could be a rough ride here
he's got seven bars
he's got seven bars he can do it
yeah you need to say no
no no no levels oh not gonna happen here
i also see almost seven dragon balls
fast facts
oh oh no good clock he drops the combo
vanish on vanessa it's my turn
yeah knock on the door oh confetti it's
a party yeah he tried it right there
tried to set it up oh not gonna be able
as long as you don't drop this cloud is
going to be set down in the first game
and that's something that you always
have to remember if you're playing
against yashar he is a connoisseur of
that float mix he was using it before it
became easier to use he is a a heavy
believer that is super super valuable in
matches as we just sort of won him the
game jasha takes the first victory for
frost hey
man that was such that was such an
amazing game cloud fought valiantly i
will say not free it wasn't free it was
not free cloud played incredibly well
there had a real a lot of really good
call outs and i was very excited to see
how he was able to control the pace of
the game joshua is no slouch the sleeper
killer from france and yasha will use
all the time the clock and that's what
we saw yasha played incredibly reserved
really controlled the pace once cloud
like he snuffed out clouds fire is what
i would like to say the cloud that's how
you make a statement because he he was
fighting he was swinging and even though
he lost you know what joshua respect on
my man's that was very good it was it
was it was really looking like cloud was
actually going to take that set like it
was super convincing
he's we all know how good he is as a
player like i'm trying to keep this
unbiased but yeah he's he's a very very
solid player and uh showing why you know
he was selected here taking it to yasha
who of course is one of france's finest
but
with that who are they going to send out
to play against yashar yeah
so if you look at the whole roster of
the team everybody who's been talking
they're like oh yeah cloud might be the
weakest on the roster everybody's from
clowning on west coast it's like okay so
if cloud is almost able to beat yasha
the cloud is almost able to beat yasha
i'm comfortable with anybody that we
send up i am comfortable with anybody as
you can see stand up and you can see the
scoreboard right here we got one
breadstick on one baguette on the board
for france we got a nice crispy doughnut
on the side of usa you need five points
to move on but we have four players on
side cloud is greyed out for now he will
be coming back in the second set later
in the day but as you can see still a
five-man strong yacht roster on the side
of the french but yasha has to stay on
does indeed man it's gonna be tough um
i but i i wonder if
if we get confirmation that the players
are allowed to switch teams like could
could you i should play a different team
now or does he have to stick with the
same team
yeah yeah so they can change assist but
they can't change their teams unless
they lose so here's what we're going to
be doing we're going to be going over
the match right now to see who team usa
is going to send to defeat yasha
send it
thank you very much jake uh i might need
sage with me right now just for 30
seconds my friend
uh
just two questions the first one is what
did you think about the first set i know
that cloud played well what what did you
think about it
uh it was pretty good man day four cloud
powerful man
honestly i have no idea what happened
like uh he did one block string for
vegeta or vegito through the key blast
got hit that's so annoying man that
caused the whole game but man club
played really good man i'm
i was late that was good all right you
did very good so for the next question
obviously who's going to be the next
player for your team
next up is hook gengar
who
god is next ladies and gentlemen yasha
stay on site because the rules is winner
stays on you can come hook you can have
a seat and i'm going back to syrah le
francais and jake ryan
merci merci we're back thank you so much
yeah are we going to be getting this one
hook versus yasha coming up man so
they're sending them in this is one one
of the big dogs right away this is going
to be good honestly if hook wins this
jill is going up to that stamp
if hook wins this they're sending julo
100
i'm not gonna happen i'm not gonna lie
throughout the tournament yesterday like
going into it yeah like i know who
played a ton of games like before like
200 or so matches yeah and you could
really see throughout the tournament
that
yeah you could see that like that fire
that we saw from him you know in in the
earlier seasons of the game you know you
could really see and i was talking to
him as well and he's you know he loves
the offline environment oh yeah like
this is where these guys thrive man so
you love to see it man and uh seeing
hook come back with that super powerful
piccolo brolly shell yeah you put any
character on that roster yeah it's a
pretty good team it's a pretty good team
and i'm i'm excited to see hook play
because hook learned a lot from
yesterday he was in the play room he's
been still continuing to grind and learn
and make adjustments and i want to see
what adjustments are making we had just
had like two hours before we started um
earlier today
where there was even more practice time
and the french players have also been
feeding they've been playing this entire
time playing everybody i think
everybody's gotten sets with everybody
um so it's gonna be really exciting to
see what adjustments are there
absolutely yeah it's gonna be great man
like these guys are
they've just really been grinding it out
this weekend and and preparing for today
because we're here at the main event now
yesterday the 16 man bracket you know
after these guys were getting eliminated
they were you know they were off
scheming exactly they killed planning
you know yeah they were there right
there getting ready for today um and you
know they've been going over strategies
i i know they were playing in the in the
practice room because we had like shout
outs to the team by the way like they
hooked us up with a uh an entire
huge like room in the hotel oh it's like
a practice room like yeah then that's
like 24 hours so these guys are in there
grinding it out and just coming up with
new ideas and things like that so um
yeah they really did have the time to
prepare and get ready but we
um
oh yeah okay okay i just got the
confirmation there you finally lose
change teams when you lose one match wow
okay so josh is stuck he's sticking with
that team
yeah you can change your assist whenever
you want but when you lock in you are
stuck on that team you can't you can't
even change it's like not
yeah you can lose one oh that's right
you could lose one match on purpose just
to change your team yeah i mean i mean
josh
let's be honest right he picked this
team for a reason yeah he did he like
he's probably been developed this
developing this team in the back you
know just uh
specifically for today yeah we know him
usually for the teen gohan vegito based
goku
the huge damage team but you know he's
going for a different one this time and
you can see right there the scoreboard
looks a 2-1 victory um over cloud and
we're going to get on with the next
match guys of course we can see right
there it's gonna be hook and god versus
yasha let's get straight into it throw
over to my guy rizza let's get it
aaron appreciate this man we're moving
on to the second game of the day ladies
and gentlemen for the french team we're
still having yasha on the left side so
that's really cool for him
on the right team cloud unfortunately
lost again but it was close it was 2-1
he did pretty well hook is now
on the set with piccolo and z broly good
luck to yasha ladies and gentlemen let's
get it started
yeah we are going to get into this match
now hook gang god versus yasha and like
i said if hook takes this jill is 100
going up to that stand i am excited to
see hook play i want to see if he made
any team adjustments because something
we found out here bass vegeta is an
incredibly strong character however
super saiyan 4 gogeta really circumvents
a lot of his options a lot of the
characters that the french play have
barriers or they utilize full screen
lariats and it really just makes it hard
for vegeta to start that like peppering
pressure with the keyboard i know what
you're saying like a lot of uh good
options in neutral to kind of just get
around projectiles and things like that
yeah there's there's a lot of that um
they have a lot of those strategies over
here yeah but let's try and see how this
one unfolds guys this is going to be an
absolute banger of course again
hook thank god we all know how this guy
is how good this guy is you know he's
been doing it for a long time i can see
the the boys in the chat uh coming out
to to represent got the whoppo's out
here yeah the guapo's in chat
let's get it nice vegeta
he's keeping on the same team i really
like this decision
changing at this point would be a little
bit too hard especially you do not have
enough time to get a character to the
level that you need to deal with the
french players so guapo's in chat you
know what to do okay god versus yasha
wow
very clean hit right there dealing with
the assistant dropping the combo not
sure what's going on right there and
yasha in the interview if you didn't
notice that before he said he really
wanted to play against a true champion
yeah he said this is a player that has
uh inspired him
with one and two
of course you know he's one of the guys
really just holding it down and fighting
now
showing up worldwide
makes it happen that's what you love to
see
okay go throwing them up in a time
has a sizeable life now i might even hit
the spot let's see oh he actually was
still going to block that he actually
doesn't jump oh no the raw attack after
the reflex so smart from yasha gets his
character out doesn't even need to spark
very good stuff from yasha
final camera hello my heart let's see
that was very clean you'd love to see it
see the optimal there the two engines of
the sword yeah
show me what you got gets the tag into
the dragon rush thank you mechanics
so good for this character man
[Applause]
i'm sorry but he dropped it sparky give
me my piccolo mr green oh and you saw
that he knew he was going to let him use
the blue combo so he used the
opportunity to bring it
that was so smart from hook
it's so good vegito a is the way
okay
bringing them down wrecker sequence
level three now
yash's android 17 trying to open up the
z bully
hooks defense has been looking so
impressive as i say that opened up
commentators i'm sorry
you did it to him that was definitely a
mid but he dropped the couple again
yasha
not able to finish his plate right now
you see fully still on the screen
wow i can't i can't there's too many
overheads yeah i mean i respect the
attempts of blocking out he didn't panic
he didn't guard cancer anything
very scary to block this character no
the guard can't get punches piccolo is
no longer going to be a problem
big green is now small green small green
getting planted putting the dirt done
oh we got the the kind of fight right
there as well that's the best fight in
dbc by the way
i want to confirm that with the blitz i
think he's actually dead he's done i
think
josh up with the awareness first game is
going to go convincingly over to joshua
[Applause]
all
right
that was that was that was a wash
i'm sorry i can't root for my boy there
that was a wash joshua i mean when you
don't lose a character and you use the
spark yeah on the winning combo
that's when it looks kind of rough he
didn't know how to get away from the 17
pressure he looks like he talked to
nokami he got all the routes
he got the 17t tech
it was looking common one side of that
one side but let's see the adjustment
you started out with dpp yes
so yeah so the thing that's really scary
about this team is you can round start
dp call vegeta
and not get punished because what you
can do actually like if you have a
character that has a good approach move
or an invincible move like that yeah
with that g08 it's basically round star
you know the opening gambit is pretty
much guaranteed to go your way you can
harvest super dash break confirm the
orbs wow
piccolo master
he's trying guys he's trying so hard to
pepper in these key
smart kick there h
drop and look look at the conversion
here with piccolo assist and there's
another hopefully
the orb is there
oh you gotta hold up this pressure
though i like that
vanish on vanish you are still stuck orb
is there and he blocks the rod i get the
best wow joshua great tank but the
rocket kick larry
that was that was a peak of fire
five in front that was that was that was
kind of nice hook i'll see you snatched
very good stuff continuing the pressure
trying to get his assist back rolly is
here
oh the cannonball but no we tried the 2h
i imagine
look looking clean getting out of the
corner no you cannot lock me down wow
france is popping off right now
of course they are respectfully so
all right here we go level three on the
way november gonna
no yes
[Music]
he reflected on his actions that was
such a good dragon rush josh uh
playing out of his mind right now wasn't
trying to escape
it's so good dude this character is a
problem
like we said joshua is the sleeper
strength of france right now and we are
definitely seeing that putting the work
in not only against cloud but now
looking god in a pretty precarious
situation still has sparked but this
does not look great
no assist oh he's saving okay i respect
it he's just trying to block it out and
then he's going to save the spot oh no
he didn't want to save it oh no it's
over
it's over
it's over
wow getting as much damage on the board
as he could and now look at this broly's
coming in with level two spark and maybe
45 life
oh no mix though guys no mix though
wait a minute there's a chance it could
happen to you
it could happen to anyone okay god
trying to stay alive
we can go level three in the corner now
yes you're in trouble you gotta be able
to remember it's gone oh
it could happen to you all right all
right it can happen to anybody
hook
you know what to do with chat you know
what to do
hey we go oh man
speaking of chat man man that was
looking on his phone there for a second
oh man
he took up the frame data for android 17
he's like what can this guy do
all right he's like
oh
this is just in
he mixes
it
this is this is neutral 17 has a really
hard time playing
listen you want to talk about neutral
yasha he loves this he like he uses the
clock as his fourth character
slow down the pace as much as he can and
just chill
hook though wow
and that's
defensive dragon rush working out there
catching hook off guard not sure what he
tried but bro it is going to work out
for yasha who now
this is joshua joshua cannot change
teams because he does not lose no of
course not like he's going to stick with
this this team has been looking so good
for him um this is obviously a new
strategy he's developed because bro even
yesterday in the tournament he was not
playing this team yeah it's definitely
something that he did adjust and i've
seen him play this in casuals like for a
couple of people but having that having
a pocket team where we've been playing
against something this entire time and
you just switch it on a dime that's hard
but you know that's how you have to do
you got to be ruthless in competition
you have to be ready to switch it up
it's one of the things that we will talk
about when it comes to playing against
yasha and how what like separates him
from the rest of the french players yeah
where he usually plays that uh team
gohan um vegito blue uh bass goku right
yes like that's the team that we always
are familiar with when it comes to
yashar whereas you know wawa kaiden
these guys are just a cocaine these guys
are different changing characters like
everything doesn't matter i hate random
selecting exactly but um but for yasha
he's bringing someone new to the table
now as well and you can see right here
guys two grayed out names under that usa
flag we've got three left
i i honestly i don't know because here's
the thing our two strongest players are
to kill sage and nitro right now and
jonathan i mean jonathan has it into him
jonathan has it it's like he's a beast
you know you know you know team gohan
when android 16 says you let it go
let it go
it's okay to press square that's what
jonathan needs to do right now and we're
gonna actually see what the team
captains have to say rizza take it away
very much guys it was a great game on
both sides yasha did super one on the
game hook did well actually but this
happy birthday from yasha and the
neutral game that he played
that's crazy man i might need sage once
again i'm sorry man i have to
call you again cause i might need i
might need the next one but yeah before
that
what happened with this happy birthday
man
happy birthday bro oh dude these
defensive assists are too strong man
but it's okay no man
no that was good dude josh is playing
really well who played
he's played better i've seen better but
he played good too like it's
it's really just like the strategies
right now or just like those are
superior
i'm not going to go too in depth talk
about that later but
that was a rough one for sure all right
thank you very much said i appreciate
this but last question again who's going
to be the next pick for you guys
we're going to send our nitro bros now
nitro is coming out for the american
team
nitro please
stand up
nitro please
sit down
let's go guys tyrone it's on you man
thank you very much nitro sending in the
big guy
straight away they realized i think sage
realized i think the team realized we
need to stop this man we got to stop
them we got to stop him right gotta
who many consider to be the strongest
player out of the usa right now this guy
is an absolute beast um really really
impressive actually one of my favorites
to watch like
like completely unbiased opinion i love
watching nitro play bro yasha right now
the way he's playing
i don't know so so the thing nitro i
feel has been doing the best in sets
against everybody here in casuals but
tournament has a different story he also
made it the furthest out of all the
other americans and you know he's
getting the beats ready this man doesn't
even play with sound he is built
different yeah he is that strong nitro
there's actually a joke that's been
going on i've been like everyone was
saying oh nitro would have got that
combo and it's like but i am nitro
[Laughter]
nitro would it be wallop but i am nitro
[Laughter]
there's two ways that this can go if
nitro wins they're gonna send everybody
at him and keep wawa as the secret last
boss
everybody wants to play nitro
everybody's like i bet you everyone on
the team is like if you lose joshua i
want him i want him he's mine give him
to me and and guess what nitro is gonna
be like okay i'll take him that's that's
what i want to see either that or
they're gonna send in the big guns and
it's gonna be it's gonna be a show but i
don't know man i don't know how this
goes my boy nitro has been playing
incredibly well i don't know if he's
going to stick with the 18 for this but
he has been playing the 21
and tyrant i think we're going to be
taking it away right now as we go into
the match rizza
let's go check
two worlds
war ready yasha is still there nitro is
up on the stage now i don't know what's
going to happen right now but anyway
let's go ladies and gentlemen yeah this
is nitro for you guys let's go
[Applause]
oh man it is time it is time
and like pretty much all of these
matches man like they're all just like
dream matchups like because it's been so
long since we got to sit down and do
this properly you know do this offline
and just get everybody together get the
band back together if you want and it's
been such a good weekend man it really
has yeah this is going to be such a
great match and you know this event is
just the icing on the cake of what this
weekend has been and you know we're
getting into it he's playing 21. he's
not playing 18. nitro is playing serious
wait a minute
wait a minute why are we going to
character like oh button check they were
button checking okay okay we're making
sure we're making sure all right sorry i
got really excited i got really excited
chill out there okay now it's not time
yet it's not time it's not time for the
massacre just yet but don't worry we're
gonna get into that it was just a
preview it was a preview we're about to
get into the remix
but yeah uh i mean so when it comes to
playing against yashar
i feel like nitro is is a good counter
pikachu oh i feel like his playstyle is
definitely the one that can you know
throw a spanner in the works to yash's
very neutral base uh you know methodical
play style nitro is very
read-based and super good with the
confirmed side exactly so
um i mean i'm i'm ready for this
and nitro also has like the the young
man reactions i have seen
there's so many different like always
with the optimal punish i've seen so
many dragon rush kids jump ki blast by
kid who in the ex ball same thing with
ui goku the ied forward m and we are
getting straight to this match it's
gonna be nitro versus yasha usa needs to
get one on the board because right now
josh has taken out two of our boys and
trying to take out the third nitro
considered the best player on the team
and getting mixed quickly in the first
game up by gogeta blue a character that
so many people have written off and said
is not a good not a strong character bro
you can make any character in this game
work um but yeah we can see right there
on nitro site we know him recently
bro he's done
joshua has been having so many drops
yeah oh yeah like i said jumping every
single dragon rush
wow that's kind of nasty right there i
see you're not sure oh
oh nitro cook it it begins but yeah so
we've seen that a lot recently hit a
bunch of his android 18 you know
character that we all think challenge
with the bands on wake up
but he's going back to the trial and
tested android 21. the defensive assists
are just so strong it's just like sage
said you know you utilize them so well
and 17 gonna be going into this mix
right here so terrifying the barriers
and yeah
nitro
listen
man dr shiro
built this one differently android 17
coming here to play and that's going to
be a dead character one bar spend this
everyone does a lot of damage yep
she is done she's at it this is gonna be
rough but nitro still has ui goku in the
back one of the like he is i would say
one of the strongest ui goku's in the
world oh he's the best one they're the
best one i i think he's the best you are
number one ui in there
i mean i'll say i'm yeah i mean
obviously for france and all by mirror i
could i can i could my greatness yeah
there we go that's what i like to hear
oh
you pressed l
wow they're raining they're swinging
yasha losing that gambit though you know
getting put into the corner here knights
are going to be putting in a one-touch
situation not even going to spend the
meter oh you can't vanish but he missed
a confirm if he's super oh
okay
i see you nitro
this is why they put him up and it's
like we alluded to earlier bro the
reactions on him bro they're ridiculous
that was
that was amazing nitro young man
reactions oh what the two last whiffen
and then he got the hate reach up there
from yasha always so ready
yeah very good from yasha still fighting
back and you know nigel keeps getting
hit by mitch he's trying to escape and
you got to hold this one more time the
vanish might come out left right
definitely going to be a factor how are
you going to block oh good
for the wake up sparking keep it safe
unrestrained will into the spark you're
right keeping that one safe okay
why are you reflecting yasha come on bro
reflect on your actions
okay look down in the corner right now
nitro on the offense on the hunt right
now spark up here from yasha oh
is he gonna confirm this there's no way
there's no way he has these oh
you can't escape
nitro new york the nitrogen brothers
okay there we go boom
level three on deck right now but you've
got to think about that blue light
that's adding up right there on kojita
yeah as well and nitro does not bar here
so
they spend its game 50 50. i can't block
my head
nitro showing why he's considered the
strongest us making quick work of yasha
so far
okay here we go
he's still live this minute very back
and forth match actually here we go
final character for yeshua does have a
lot of meat and that's right jake this
character is scary he's got the esports
kick in the whale
oh wow a nice reflection
he's dead
five let's start illegal starters
defense
level two coming up i don't know what he
goes right into it okay
he just wanted to finish up once mate
wants us to watch this beautiful
animation
dead character right here and it's gonna
be kim boo the last character on the
table for nitro yeah i'm really liking
the way that yasha has been playing this
entire set too you know like playing it
slow nitro wow all right
wow nitro showing why he's a powerhouse
as well this is this is so tense yasha
known to use the clock
oh wow
the hate actually beat the supernatural
start okay yeah right now try to stay
alive in this does have a lot of bad
nitro though this is serious
yeah yeah yeah
for nitro i don't know about yasha you
actually need to clean m here he's got
level five
oh that's true
what are you playing at just finish your
plate
90 seconds
that was kind of sick
what do you mean
yo but yasha with a big drop and bro
this is the kind of thing that we
honestly i never had yesterday down as a
kind of player that really like chokes a
lot he's normally very very solid in the
game but yesterday we saw it against wow
and we've seen it today he could have
just finished that combo and it was over
how did he do that i just i don't know
i don't know how he dropped that but
nitro
how did he
how did he react like that i told you i
said it right at the beginning of the
set he consistently jumps the command
grabs jumps the dragon rushes with the
jump ass ex missing ball and exactly
what we saw right there that was such
that's there i can't see that's cheap
and i feel like in this version of the
game when the camaraderie is so potent
right you've got to have those punishes
because we all know like jumps in this
game normal jumps are a bit floaty so
you need to be ready to punish them and
uh that key blast jump key blast from
kid boo great option there
very good stuff oh mix good blocks nitro
he got hit with that the first time in
the first game but this time he's
blocking yeah wow such a good raw tag
him and down back are good friends but
now you go
make a statement
oh my goodness drop the combo
and yasha fighting back but ah that's
such a smart punish he waited just
wanted to see if he was going to vanish
half the 2h on deck if needed and now
getting a confirmed yashar looking
strong not being shaken by that first
loss yeah and there we go again that
special tag out so effective for a
character like gogeta blue yes and now
level three on deck and nitro might even
consider okay
hold it north like that okay wow
yasha your mix i've seen it
i am mr ultra instinct there he is he's
up on the table right now strongest goku
in history gonna get this level three
and now yashar might
i don't know about spark probably not
wow
and you know that ex even with the
changes he's going to get his meter back
pretty soon meter penalty is gone and
this is going to be a dead 17 always
doing the saucy combo
yeah there we go
optimum stuff getting as much
as much as he can
but now yasha okay
double blue head boys yeah joshua can
still make this come back vegito with
sparking is an incredibly strong anchor
you still have the blue gogeta as well
we saw the mix that he's able to provide
but now nitro playing incredibly lame
full screen come on you approach me you
got to hit me
oh that confirmed wow yasha you're nasty
yeah that concern was kind of ridiculous
all right here we go level one into
level three i imagine here just gonna
get that
yeah situation trying to force out maybe
i'm restrained from nitro here might
just chill block let's find out yeah he
has sparking left too you want to keep
the whole team are you going to hold
this pressure yeah it doesn't even care
there's no issue wow okay
ooh attacking
but we're also getting opened up that
dragon rush does work out here for the
usher gonna get the knock down once
again
back
you made a mistake frenchman oh the
stairs
i'm falling oh okay okay
that's a real kid right there yeah
okay one into one and that should be
done right there two characters a piece
now
fair gaming this is pretty fair nitro
still got sparky this is a even game but
sparking is running lower on yasha right
now you gotta be incredibly careful nice
replay oh
nitro getting caught that was the best
part was you couldn't have timed it
worse unfortunately for him he might be
dead yeah into the final coming of my
heart i think this is gonna override
that level two spa just about wow
that is a critical mistake from nitro
right there that's unfortunate because
that's [ __ ] blast like that
it was at range where you know the the
push back doesn't kick in exactly
so just whipping it completely that was
such a good confirm knew that he wasn't
sparking goes for the empty vanish this
again this is a 50 50 two-touch game
both sides sparking is going to run out
on the side of the night but you gotta
guess yasha are you gonna save your
character yeah this is gonna be some of
the best level three mix in the game
stays in front here good luck from yasha
just chilling right now
oh
block the tail though
again
never doubt the 6m like these guys will
block the craziest like stuff you've
ever seen and they just get clipped by
that yeah that's you can't you can't
write it out for sure yeah it's hard and
and you know nitro uses it pretty
sparingly so yoshi getting caught by it
you're not looking for that typically
all right but this is scary 120 both of
these both these players will play full
screen like you can see here and then
meet in the middle super jump around
each other
oh wow he tried to punish oh nitro stay
alive in this as is yasha both players
just this movement from both and
remember if yoshi loses us he's got to
get off the setup not able to confirm
okay
you know yasha wants to do as much as he
can for his country but nitro wants to
be the one to take off that guy
yeah send him down give me more matches
you gotta be looking out for that as
well
oh is any mistake any mistake or kill
look at this there's been a whole minute
of just jumping around oh oh the double
oh
he got the side switch if he optimizes
he should be able to kill yeah
yeah yeah yeah send him ex oh you don't
even need it level three have a snack
sit on the bench here's your dessert
yasha goodbye nitro getting a win on the
board we gotta back it too wow there you
go man yashar right there
has to be taken down uh you know one of
these guys pretty good
yeah pretty good he did he did well you
know he took down two two opponents but
bro and nitro just looking this guy is
built in front we all know this yeah
super good player um but man yasha is
going to go down but now it's up to the
french guys to decide who they want to
send up to play against that guy who a
lot of people are saying the strongest
guy out of the us right now and
the thing is like you look at the rest
of that roster and anybody there
king kane got third yesterday
second wawa got first and i think kaiden
got fourth
so like that the fact that that's that's
oh man well that's how we have who we
have left we might we might have a cane
versus nitro rumba that actually oh that
could happen
that would be really good that would be
really good i'm sure that's what uh
nitro at once but with that guys we are
ready to find out who it's going to be
we can talk through rex all day but
let's find out first fire over to riza
let's go
it was a crazy game though nitro played
out of his mind and he did pretty well
sending back yasha to the seat it's
crazy man
i need you please with me on the
microphone i'm asked i might ask you
what did yasha wrong on the past game
i think uh
okay i think yasha
just played real real well uh
since the beginning he just eliminated
uh cloud and uh and uh
that's really really cool for us
and it's okay to
to lose right now because we have an
amount of guys with that really really
strong today and
for that game
he just i think the drop for the first
game
it was really intense for him because he
didn't know the the recap for gojita
the ll was just slide knocked down not
for the for the ll medium and that's why
he just dropped for the
level five and uh
it's okay because
it's good and we got an amount of guys
don't worry about that okay thank you
very much
so the last question as usual who's
going to be the next pick for the french
players
we've got another player who
like like like a friend josquel uh the
next one is uh a french
rap
from 94
who is called the master of wanted
aka
guys
the game the game you've been waiting
for on the internet is happening right
now
nitro versus gaiden
live right now tyrant
we're going to get it this has been one
of the dream matches that a lot of
people have been talking about though
this is a dream match we want to see
what's he kind of versus nitro you know
the two guys that have been blowing it
up during this lockdown era of online
you know they've really flourished and
now we get to see it in the offline
environment bro
come on that's right we actually didn't
get to see this yesterday because
kaiden didn't get top four kaiden lost
to wawa and wawa had to play nitro so we
already got that dream match but now
i've been waiting to see this in a
tournament setting yes for a very long
time because kaiden actually arrived
late to like he only arrived on like
saturday like saturday morning or like
friday night didn't really get to play
any games went straight to bed so titan
is the person i got to see played the
least and i don't think that nitro
really got that many sets with him and
kaiden has so many teams he's showed me
the power of genemba like
i oh man i didn't have the question mark
percentage and i i think a first to two
favors nitro 100 favors nitro because
kaiden like get
you you got he warms up he warms up yeah
yeah okay
i can see that for sure i can see that
that's a fair point um don't think it's
going to go down that way
that's that's nice if you have an
opinion like that jake no no i mean
honestly like it could go either way uh
but we
we know how how strong both these guys
are and this has been anticipated so
built up for a reason yeah we all want
to see nitro vs kaido and we're going to
get our wish in just a moment i think
the players are just setting the scene
right now just getting those buttons
checked just making sure they're all
they're all good you can see right there
nitro is getting ready to show some more
um
wonderful ui stuff i feel like this is
the strongest ui out there yeah after
after that showing and especially with
the reaction decisions like maybe even
one of the strongest kid boos because
you see the optimal staircase combos you
see the great extensions with the
gumball assist you see everything it's
the complete package yeah yeah yeah we
could talk about characters all day best
is best dad best at but so the end of
the day it's all about improving
yourself as a player overall and uh
nitro has been doing that tenfold but
bro kaiden is just
i don't know man like
this guy is is the one that can
really really uh
decide this set i think yeah i feel like
this week it's going to go down but
we're ready we're going to throw over to
rizza right now to bring us into this
exciting dream match let's go bro
everybody was waiting for it since
i don't even know for six or seven or
eight months but anyway 16 weeks winner
of the wanted 19 weeks in a row we know
of the wanted kaiden on my left side the
best american player right now on the
right side nitro
francaise let's get it later
oh man
this is
king of europe versus king of the east
king hoc king king of the whole us right
now right this is yeah this is going to
be wait look at kaiden's team look at
guidance
this is the classic kind of team this is
the one that we all know him for
originally but like yeah he's like we
said before
the french players all
worked out to each other playing all
kinds of different teams
but this is the team that really brought
in his success first of all
cooler android 18. let's go and it's
it's the defensive assist once again
that show up really strong but kites
kefla is
it's pretty unmatched crosstalk is
pretty close but my goodness you master
you challenge nitro
oh six seconds kraken
all right taking the dr there you go
like that
and honestly like we talk about complete
packages i feel like these two are very
very similar in that respect okay very
very nice here we go kefla bring you to
the corner that situation right there he
saw the barrier and he has been getting
dragon rushed in barriers so much he
immediately tried to dragon rush and got
picked up kaiden reading nitro like a
book bro this level three though cheap
as hell look at this
boots to the back of the head
got clipped and now kippu's gonna go
down that's ugly that's ugly that's not
fair that's cheating
that's mix
oh full screen neutral you can't even
call your friends
what you see the float and then the same
side dps system all right yeah
very solid
wow how did he block that how
all right no punishing the barrier great
tackle dragon rush nitro trying to fight
back
no nice roll with the drop at that
moment you had to be a little more
patient young man oh feels bad that is a
heartbreaker right there man
it's not good look but we'll take those
all right we'll take those that was
gonna be huge kaiden's happy about that
mistake but that that might be the drop
of the game
oh
july
offense guys
i haven't seen this character in so long
i'm happy to see him he's sick
he's super good i feel like cooler has
like for a long time been one of the
most underrated characters in the game
yeah kaiden yup
all right nitro
wow there's already so many dragon balls
to work with too i'm not i wanna i wanna
see shenron at least once
very good stuff level three this is a 50
50. kaiden has to has to respect this or
you have to you don't have sparky you've
got to hold this broken level three
broken good luck
okay all right backing off here the
patient neutral
[Music]
chilling is popping off
wow get us back to the match
wow she stopped the mud hole in his ass
hook killer oh no gaiden looking so
strong with the re-jump swag come on
these characters
[Music]
and that is going to be the first game
going to kaiden
yeah there we go
kevlar
and that's gonna do it right there
kaiden takes the first game over nitro
looking a bit quiet over there on the us
side of things jake no no no no no no i
don't want to talk about it he's warming
up he's warming up okay yeah everybody
gets one everybody gets one okay nitro
nitro knows what to do he's going to
turn it on
it's all right we're going right back
into it no switch no nothing ah 2m
starter
this is this is hurting
all right
okay knock down here all right we need
that game audio right back asap please
cool
oh good reflect key blast coming out
very nicely nice
running out
stuff's the cooler
got to hold oh wow punishing the dragon
rush landing at the perfect time that
was a great back that's from metro and
he gets a good punch on that as well
here we go not down time are you
spending the level three yes scream on
him
i respect it he's trying to just force
spark out kaiden but i don't think kylie
will use it he's really confident in his
defense
there it is no confidence to be had
there mystic ball out but the 5m goes so
far but the miss confirmed because
a little too excited that was definitely
a 2h did not come out in time kaiden now
has to hold this pressure you have no
more sparking and you've got to help
this mix jumping out very good
ah the overhead is just so strong you
can't challenge in the barriers there as
well yeah 6h overhead man it's a full
sense of security you see you've got
opportunity that barriers there boom you
get opened up okay here we
yeah go what
what yeah i guess you are like using the
17 theme is kind of risky actually
because of that you can get hit yeah
oh no
[Music]
paul in the home calling the brother
oh super dash punish
back gaiden it's not gonna be free okay
all right trust me you know how good i
am you know how good i am oh very good
stuff that's what i want to see nice
blocks in the mix
oh my goodness did you see that sequence
right
there he could take his turn but no
i think he's got caught on the on his
jump rings right there
that 2h kaiden
today you are really reacting the odd
boots are doing work today bro
okay let me go level one into another
level one will seal the deal here oh my
goodness number one we'll talk about
damage bro
so good
man tyrone i don't know how this is
gonna go right now sparking is still
available on the side of nitro you of
the strongest 21s as well wow
he's free to the overhead alien toast we
don't have any coolers
in the us okay wow okay
show me the sauce show me the sauce no
wait why you went for a reset maybe
just keep it simple nitro
just keep it simple
yeah one into one again
my goodness bro it is not looking good
the us hope nitro
just finish your food just finish your
food nitro every all three of these
characters one time full screen ex larry
at the starter big
big cat
we got we're not big neph here we got
big kev
no big left big cap
does it work wow
okay he's in this he's in this nicer had
enough okay and you get the goddamn key
on this as well not kill though
oh do you want to play like that
you had time
nice roll well kaiden felt felt
disrespected after that he chose
violence
does it from angles where like you can't
do h it's so smart i mean even though
21's 2h is so good
don't talk to me tyrone i'll talk to you
supernova make him feel it oh i'll talk
to you
don't talk to me tyrion
what are you saying though don't talk to
me don't talk to me tyrant
don't talk to me hey come on it's not
tyrant today it's
okay don't talk to me they blessed me
don't talk to me don't talk you know
i've got the best os i don't care who
wins because i'm uk but like
i can still rep for my boys and you'd
love to see it tied and doing work
taking down nitro
all i gotta say now now what
now what to kill sage it's the time it's
time it's time it's time to kill city
and then and then jonathan
let it go
oh
let
i mean that i mean that that's the
national champion right there for the
west coast he is the national champion
definitely a beast but you know showing
up here when you've got all these
killers on the stage it's gonna be rough
you can see right here two players
remain it's the jonathan tenei and the
kill sage desk village that's true
it's time to kill plants
we might we might see a certain
character on the screen i'm saying sage
has prepared something i hope that he i
hope he goes forward with his word i
mean i don't think we're gonna have too
much time here uh for us to talk because
there's only two players to choose from
so relax
relax relax all right
all right hey hey remember remember
there's two sets
give you a little breakdown on the
format there's only the first set all
right
you know we lick our wounds okay nitro
will come back stronger faster
yeah nastier
exactly we will we will see nitro um
there will be of course another set but
yeah this is the first one still guys
thank you for tuning in and we're gonna
throw over to our z8 my guy so we can
find out who the next challenger for
kaiden will be
this was a crazy exciting game ladies
and gentlemen i was waiting to see this
set happening in real life kaiden won
but i can't even brag about it because
nitro was really good he had two or
three drops we cost him the game yep it
is what it is man he's going to play
again tonight so that's fair i believe
sage i need you again please one more
time
what do you think about this game
there we go games
thank you sage it was a pleasure man so
who's playing next
it's my turn i'm gonna go up
the captain is there ladies and
gentlemen so let's go sit tight on the
right side
jake tyrant it's a new voice
you know that is that is some that has
some trust from the kill sage to not
save himself for last because jonathan
where are we hoping let it go
it's time it's time for desk village
guys we're going there we're going to
get back get the plans and check out oh
i can see it right there's kill plans in
chat it's time the the squad's coming
out here representing you'd love to see
it but brock hayden is just looking
ridiculous today bro bringing out the og
team as well um
man it's like and it goes back to that
that um familiar story of preparing for
the french players is just a nightmare
in itself because you don't know what
team they're going to play like i'm sure
they were looking at kaiden's team he
was playing yesterday you know one of
his other ones he's been playing online
perhaps what's the original put out the
original
the tried and true i don't think i've
seen a cooler in a competitive match on
stream a bandai stream in like two years
i mean since dagura since dawgara combo
yes breaker stream for the dragon ball
world tour that's the last time i have
seen a competitive cooler i commentated
that match and lord buller was
definitely mixing yeah he's definitely
an underrated character you know kylan's
made multiple uh impressive performances
with this with this team with this
character top eight at spain saga in
season two i believe he made he made top
eight in the uh lcq finals for the world
tour in season two as well so yeah he is
um he's definitely been doing work with
his character for a long time um and we
are ready guys for this next exciting
game of course the kill stage versus
kaiden out of france and man usa needs a
dub up there we need to get it up we
need it we need to we need to sage it's
time extraterrestrial pressure all right
reza take it away
america
if you need to do something it's right
now
the boss is dead but they've got the
secret boss so i don't know what's gonna
happen but anyway kaiden good luck sage
good luck
all right guys get on with it more
exciting matches coming your way of
course still in the first set now so if
you just tuned in here on twitch.tv
dragonball fighterz you know you've
still got a whole bunch of games ahead
of us today um you know tons to go here
so
what team is he playing he's not playing
the alien he didn't switch he told me he
was going to play jiren oh you told me
he was going to play he's got a german
team he's got jiren for the vegitos but
he's got to lose a match in order to
pull him out but
jiren is in the pocket okay okay i mean
i mean it makes sense i i get it for the
counters and stuff all right here we go
great start here for kaiden
once again going to work and kefla
boy this patch is a bit of a demon
is very strong
wow
okay here we go look at this this place
vegeta is in trouble right now look at
those new combos as well wait
okay no enough here to i think you can
maybe
doesn't matter oh my goodness
vegeta got rinsed right there
oh my goodness he got he got opened up
made i don't know what happened in that
situation but sage still has z pulley
he's gonna play two characters this game
not three the second two games
oh no
wow
kyle is
cooking right now
look at this
thick body getting marked legendary
super saiyan action right now yeah this
is kefla versus the original
this is this is going to be rough
there's mix in this situation you have
18 in the back this is going to be so
hard kind of barrier you can't really
challenge sparking immediately yeah you
can't afford to take it
good luck
[Applause]
sage fighting back
yeah don't count stage out third place
world tour final season two you know
this guy
has
i feel like that towards the end of
season two that was where we really saw
the true sage you know his real
potential was was uh
was revealed there
but it's time to tap back into that
energy bro exactly
love to see it
nice extension from the item had to
bring the spark to escape but sage also
has no spark so fighting there
converting the drop
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
in my hands for free
okay there we go cupcakes on deck
let's see
fifty percent life gone on quite inside
on that and rating great block though
defensively calling that cooler assist
and this is something that sage has
picked up on you know he's oh no
that is one of the dirtiest cross-ups in
the game
her job m as well
okay
one into one into three lord bula bring
him in for the supernova
throw it at her
and let's get down to it let's bring in
the final boss the demon bro
this is this is where this is sage's
character sage developed this character
sage put everything into broly he is
this would be the character to make it
happen right now i mean he was doing it
before it was cool yeah exactly
when playing the big body character was
like seen as a just an instant loss
sage made it work yeah but now i'm gonna
be trying to make it work hitting the
other big body character cooler on the
screen level three
there's there's he's gotta get like five
touches
that's a lot that's a lot of hits
the challenge from kaiden
this is so much damage yeah i think he's
dead yeah the supernova is going to send
it back to the stone age oh he has a
little bit off left
it begins it begins it could happen to
you he can't get touched he can't get
sneezed on he's still got a chance he's
still got a chance but
there's not much life on his side not
much i say there's like a magic pixel
there's no life
hey core barrier up
okay ryden right here
oh you've got sniped bro
from there you have to shield up for a
second and then just this shield
dissipated and he threaded the needle so
perfectly
sage knows oh hyden was looking out for
that but bro
first game will go to him another like
i'm not gonna lie like an uphill battle
but there we go opening gambit pays off
the stage he's playing three characters
that's true did he get baseball oh the
last game
to him starter he should be dead he
should be dead don't drop the stage hope
you like nitro today
okay hilarious so funny right
okay
cooler coming in now
that was good hey that's that's the
opposite of what happened in the first
game
this is what i'm talking about with sage
he's woken up he could just turn it
around
sage doesn't like losing that like that
not me
all right let's see
oh wait no you don't have this you don't
have these there's no way no no no it's
not it's not a tod but he's going to get
a good situation for himself
cooler with spark is terrifying now 18
was smart is even scarier this is going
to be really hard you have to block a 50
50 here you could potentially get a kill
off of this kaiden looking to even up
the character score
okay here we go what's it gonna be
from sage all that blue live coming back
that was an excellent spark right there
look at how he turned out around
and he got all his life back yeah that's
huge he didn't touch me
[Music]
oh okay okay okay okay
[Music]
wow that was cheap that was cheap
okay
all right right now trying to keep this
corner position
sage defense
wow good reflex but you're still stuck
all right once again all over ahead gets
there here okay kaiden right now needs
to make this count there's no spark
available either
you can't block forever yeah not gonna
be able oh another drop kite not sure
what's going on here you can't talk any
of your assists oh the float they saw
here
kind of backed off back to
just out of range that android 17 okay
taking care of him that's very good
russ that was cheeky he had the assist
he wasn't thinking a dragon rush coming
you thought it was traditional mix was
spend your cash right now all of it all
right you're only in paris once
okay let's get it sage right now
what a turnaround for that first game oh
my armor you can't wake up with buttons
there
oh my the armor for the knight of the us
right now keeping it together eg to kill
sage the genius himself versus kaiden
are we going to get an even match right
now are we going to get a set the kill
plan is in action it looks like that's
right that the kill plan is working but
no cooler the tail is longer than 21 and
she is gone her tail is done listen
that's not cool that's lord
all right here we go
movie boss's showdown right now oh yeah
this is the number one movie who's the
number one movie boss right now
wow
it's unblockable that's been two times
the alien toes have blessed burley he's
only got three of them but man they're
doing work yeah that's multiple times
right there
[Applause]
my man was he was here and then he was
behind that was dirty and now it's gonna
be face vegeta versus booger
remember
he can go through he is a hard matchup
for base vegeta in neutral
this is so smart and this is like sage
right now fight for the pride of the us
trying to stay alive in this
oh three ah so scary projectile
invincibility yeah
okay
all right all right trouble here not
dead not dead jake
situations
okay all right i'll see you i see you i
see all right sage all right came to
play sage is here
guys he's here he's got deep breath sage
thank you one for from america take
kiting out the strongest in europe
and they thought they you know what back
up those statements i know what you said
on twitter i know what you said on
twitter
yeah that's right
the the talk has been talked and now
it's time to play it's time to play the
game
all right here we go
[Applause]
will get this knocked down in the corner
once again that basically are really
coming in clutch to save that last game
and those loops bro there were the loops
of his life you do not want to be
dropping those there you need to get all
those leaks right now
make sure everything is clean
nice playing neutral incredibly well
here waiting for the assist come back
but the key last conversion from kind in
the pickup
all right here we go
i need all the kill plans i can get in
the chat right now
auto combo square band society doing
doing work out here and that's going to
be dead
there's a dead space vegeta on the side
of sage we saw what he was able to do
with it in the first the second game and
now not getting to play the character
this time kaiden's still with full hell
this is going to be rough but brawley
the original oh
okay oh look how much bar he just gave
oh
my skies
okay here we go he's gonna get
nice little bit of damage here and that
corner
this village oh no that's a barrier into
a dps that's just not bad come on
the defense is too strong
okay there we go and it's gonna be the
down time
is definitely a question mark percentage
right now this is two power bulleting
finally
oh no no
happy birthday
oh look at this
[Applause]
that catches two characters guys that
level three is gonna seal the deal haydn
is gonna take it two one over the kill
stage
oh sometimes it'd be like that man the
happy birthdays happen and
with that a 4-1 position for khan's sake
i don't know don't talk to me don't talk
to me
listen it feels it feels bad right now
don't talk to me it feels bad man it
feels bad don't talk to me come on
that's all right
man
you're all right come on it's okay
you'll get through this together let it
go it's okay depressed square look at
fruitis don't worry jonathan is my only
hope right now kuba if you're out there
please i mean tell them what you need to
tell them because that score on the
board one to four does not does not look
good for the us right now listen this
this song sounds kind of fit in a car
life this is why this is our u.s deep
dog right now
[Music]
that's not this is my circus music right
now tyrant oh
no that's all differently right now
let's go oh man jonathan
i need to see 10 out of 10a today please
i hope you remembered how to block it's
time it is time the national
champion needs to step up and represent
his region right not like this tyrant
not like this
okay okay okay but let's talk let's talk
national champion optimization station
on brawley feel like incredibly strong
blue goku look at the curls to kill sage
junior right here definitely one of the
um
the most optimal broly's out there one
of the most optimal brawlers i've like
you see the stuff he does in bracket and
what he's able to do online
transitioning to offline is always great
to see yeah i just
the the the four the four that are ahead
of him kai first you gotta be kidding
then you got one oh yeah you look at
that lineup and you got gila when you
break it down like that and then you
have kane
you have to win four grand finals i'm
all right four grand finals all right
four
just one bubba that's eight that's eight
games at a hundred percent i'm throwing
in the towel if i see that i don't have
a oh hold on where is it
i'm waiting for the flag in the flag
we will be waving the flag very very
soon
and uh we all know which one that's
gonna be it's going to be one
[Music]
say flag
don't you worry don't you worry guys
but man
this has been exciting to watch live
these have been really good matches and
you know we're going to be getting into
the last match i don't think i don't
think we need to ask to kill sage but we
can have he's going to raise talk to
sage one more time as we get into our
next match let's go yeah i'm sorry jake
yeah i can't talk to sedge right now
because there is just one player left in
the team
i know but yeah stage did really good
but you know what three versus three
games happy birthday that's it that's
what i hate about this game but i love
the game though anyway jonathan the last
one
good luck my friend
do your best
kaiden do your best as well anyway let's
go guys
get ready for the next battle
all right jonathan tenney the last hope
the shining hope of the red white and
blue on the left set one for set one the
second one we still have another set
after this we still have another set so
we're gonna have another another
massacre coming up all right after this
one guys don't you worry coming up
though we do
i know you're from the uk but man the
bomb you're gonna hit me with the boston
massacre right now that's messed up dude
that's my stuff i'm right here i thought
we were friends i thought we were
friends hey come on man oh come on
we're real buddies out here at the end
of the day we're all here apart from
these guys i mean i mean jill i said it
on that video best early wrong he's like
this is war he come up a block that's
right i'm saying this is war and we're
definitely losing we had top ring we did
not bring top tier weapons but
as you can see the meta has shifted the
defensive assists are incredibly strong
the base vegeta's may be plentiful but
they are not getting the results and
jonathan the last hope show me what you
can do with this yeah blue goku right
here
oh reactions
kaiden
question mark percent bro
i think you guys i think kaiden has
almost gotten the first hit in every
single one of the games and defense is
what jonathan is good at he will make
love to down back and that he definitely
let go
what input did you say down back yeah
i'm sorry
i'm sorry tyrone please because the
shoelace is already in the car i'm
already in the carpet tyrant this the
running in the carpet man stopped his
toes there though
i'm already dead
i'm already dead
so there we go blue goku goes down here
comes android 21 for jonathan telly but
is it 10 out of 10 today let's find out
because right now kailyn is looking kind
of nasty kaiden kaiden it doesn't matter
if jonathan's 10 out of 10. gaiden's 100
ah right right right
okay blocks it out plus frames
respect to me
i like that challenge actually you know
you can't let him get away with that the
plus rates come after you know
that was such a good challenge right
there from jonathan i may have spoken
too soon all right no massacre today
jonathan fighting back for america 50
50. and the thing about jonathan he's
incredibly technical he's not going to
mess up this 50-50 and it's it's going
to be good to watch let me show you show
me young man smart king didn't want to
hold any of you yeah you don't want to
risk it right in that situation 38 she
knows about those key blasts
from android 21.
okay
the androids are in here
excel dance
is gonna be a 50 50 in on itself call
wow okay yeah spark
nice and loud
yeah you can't block forever yeah yeah
jonathan really outstanding player like
he's so good at just uh pressuring you
to just cracking you your defense you
know yeah very good and again another 50
50. you have to hold this once again i
didn't already sparks here so you can't
escape you can't escape twice and then
the blocks are so clean
using the purple steel let's get him
with the dirty stuff hyder might be on
any uh question mark with sam right now
but jonathan tennis looking like he's on
kinder percent right now
the bueno percent all right
he's easy in his daily feeling of
kindergarten
the other room is stopped guys
okay
jonathan 10a
is here to play showing up wow with the
extension into the level three off on
the side switch okay jonathan okay okay
okay jonathan the young man it's level
three all right here we go some of the
best okay in the entire game kind of
forced to defend here and does so
successfully so far oh yeah
yo his tech actually got him the the the
r yeah like he saw that vr reacted but
it was too far away unfortunately for
jonathan there it's gonna be close on
damage here to kill as well this does a
lot level one level three it might be a
pixel but one time
supernova might have the super damage
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
the magic pixel oh he's the first person
to punish him
you're not ready listen that's the data
from watching him like he got he got
away with that on stage a few times yeah
doing his homework watching from the
back from that couch getting ready and
this should be enough yeah done oh wait
it's okay so close though
oh he went for the crab
against the hit
okay
go roli
i mean this is not gonna be the most
damage in the world he might end with
level three yeah kev lokay
both of these characters are one touch
though
jonathan let it go it's okay
it's okay to fight okay hit him oh
yes
down i don't think there's gonna be
enough damage to kill but this is a one
touch
once again look at this
absolutely oh my goodness
why are you acting like i'm gonna come
and grab listen the final character
coming in now
whatever
you're dead jonathan make it happen you
have the ex crab put him in there yeah
the ex grab he's gonna have to use it
yes okay there we go swinging him down
by his tail putting him in the dirt
jonathan there we go jonathan tenney up
there
isn't
all right kind of now you know the
french team kind of like okay this is uh
this is looking
this is [ __ ] interesting now this is
violent oh and we're going straight back
into the kain did not make a team switch
fighting holding on
and jonathan not getting cracked
well i like how she just like zooms out
of there
oh again that confirms the 21st is
jonathan
i don't know he's showing up as a
different player today oh yeah
okay he had to tell him yeah do you
learn that from falls on the friends
[Music]
wow jonathan illuminating kevlar wow
what a start there what a turn around
here this is good jonathan's showing up
strong
and you said the west coast was whack
this on my boy i certainly did not [ __ ]
not you
i'm talking i'm talking about the stream
monsters oh the 3h
okay there we go
rings in
the bro again android 18.
yeah jonathan jonathan unlocked he got
out of he got out of the restoration pod
oh that was dirty
hey but that meter penalty is in effect
guys he's not gonna be able to get
enough bar here to get the kill or any
bar in fact
yeah we got all this you can't raw tag
jonathan not one to raw attack he'll
[Music]
both these characters extremely capable
two of the best in the game you know yes
right now oh good blocks oh
i gotta come here big fella you want to
talk about grabs
he did it let it go jonathan breast
swear he did it he listened he listened
i'm so happy i need to go straight to
level three here android 21 does get
once again we've seen this so much for a
reason but oaky should get some dynamics
[Music]
oh no the medium and look at the re-jump
for the obstacle damage it's going to be
so much
three sparks wow
jonathan that's going to burn out a lot
of the spark on kaiden keep it optimal
keep it as long as you possibly can
nice and another level three sparking is
gone for kaiden and jonathan is going on
a chair kaiden you gotta block this
it's gonna be high low okay let's
reflect there
oh she tried to try any time
he knows he's pressing swearing listen
what character away from getting sent to
the bench okay jonathan tennant swinging
i hope you're ready to take a little nap
your u.s boy's kind of popping off over
there all right oh let's go dude if he
beats kaiden right now oh what he was
flexing for why he's trying to stay with
your chest
wait what happened there okay
i'm trying to catch a key
this is the boy all right the defense
you can't hit him you can't hit him you
got po-po we got jonathan we got
jonathan
i don't even care extend this is four
bars he's going to kill johnny then he's
going to set got it
[Applause]
jonathan outstanding player national
champion for a reason here for a reason
but i saw a lot of doubt on this guy i
saw a lot of doubt on mr tenei [ __ ] boy
look at him he's not even shaking if
there is any way to really just show
your worth it is to take down a guy like
kylan off the french team but bro it's
not over yet there's three more guys
coming up but that was super impressive
2-0 like that how do you do i've got
i've got to say like come on that was
that was impressive
and remember like jonathan didn't he
didn't do well in the bracket yesterday
but you have to remember that and then
seeing that after taking down to kill
yeah taking down nitro jonathan shows up
and he's like all right i'll take this
guy down too easy watch i i'm gonna
attack the dragon rush i'm gonna punish
everything and that's another victory on
the board two four i'll take that i'll
take that i mean yeah i mean the
the the seemingly insurmountable
mountain just got a little bit oh yeah
shorter you know what i'm saying like
it's a little bit easier to climb we're
going straight through we got the
dynamite okay we're making the tunnels
all right railroads it looks like
they're gonna find way away around it
but man like jonathan coming up here we
do have to find out though guys who the
french is gonna send up because they've
got three absolute killers in the back
still and we're gonna throw that over to
riza right now bro talk to us
i don't know what you think about it but
i believe that tina is now the best
american player sorry nitro
it did well right you know well yeah so
did is
he sent kaiden back home on the bench i
don't know gila was good what would
happen to kaiden on this game
uh actually uh i'm just surprised i
didn't know
jonathan will be so so good at the set
against kaiden to be honest
and uh this is to him by the way but uh
we are we are we are cool at the moment
and uh we will really see soon
the the final result
okay thank you so for your team who's
going next on stage
okay who is the next and let me thinking
why not me wow gorilla city is there
okay
jill is going to play now on the left
side tenne you've got two more boys to
go through three i believe if you beat
jitter you've got wawa and kane
my man good luck bro tyrone jake it's on
you guys
that's that's exactly how i feel too we
were talking about it earlier and it's
like jonathan has to not only be kaiden
huawei jilla but ann kane it's it's hard
we saw him take down kaiden 2-0 though
and that's something no i don't think
anybody in the chat expected that like
i'm rooting for my boy i expected a 2-1
but 2-0 jonathan the craziest thing
about that is it's it's so it's a real
test it's going to be a it's going to be
a marathon right now of different play
styles different teams different
characters so coming up now jilla i
think he's come with the strategy of
right i'm just gonna i'm just gonna like
throw a spanner in the works he saw how
solid and you know collected he was
playing against a guy like hayden
this is the king of the jungle this
ain't no methodical play style we're
going to get some you know he's going
nuts right now absolutely we're going to
see the chest beating out here
we're going to see
jilla who in second place yesterday in
the tournament experience
and you can see the breakdown right here
for the matches that we've had so far
cloud and hook gang god falling to yasha
nitro taking yasha out for the nitro
falling to kaiden also to kill sage and
jonathan tenei to owing kaiden now he's
got to fight the king of the jungle
jailer the hook killer the game winner
life is hard it's hard jill is really
good
jilla plays a mean bardock oh yeah man
like he's um he's all about this this uh
very
passive aggressive play style like he'll
chill and he'll just like you know
that's a great way to describe it and
then boom like he'll just hit you with
just a flurry of offense and like when
he's behind when he's behind the bars in
the zoo he's like yeah i'm fine and then
like the door gets open it's time to
play we're partying it's time we're
partying yeah but um i'm i'm really
looking forward to seeing this one and
it's the uphill battle honestly um for
for jonathan here you know it has to be
said you know regardless of that super
impressive performance 2-0
we've got to do three more
so i think we are with that guys we are
ready to get on with the match um let's
do it let's throw it back over to rizzo
thank you very much guys appreciate this
appreciate the strength of your cast but
we've got the game ready standing on the
right side tila on the left side ladies
and gentlemen
man jonathan is so focused right
chilling he's chilling he just he he
knows what he has to do he knows the
insurmountable task that is in front of
him oh
jules playing his original team og team
he's doing it
yeah he's going back regardless of him
thinking maybe yamcha you know maybe not
the strongest in the game a lot of the
guys here are going back to their roots
we're seeing we've seen them play a lot
of their original characters i'd love to
see it you know
um
okay there we go that's super dash
connects and now jonathan will get the
knock down here so goku got you in the
corner so here's something here's
something that i do not like about this
team that i do not like and we gotta get
the names changed but i don't like this
gelatin because remember what we said
before the us we're having a hard time
with the assist from vegito not the
character on one himself and jonathan
was of a geo player himself originally
yeah yeah yeah absolutely still um
dabbled with the character a little bit
in the lab perhaps but right now it is
about jealous vegeta that is going
and the thing is jonathan also was a
yamcha player this was part of his
original team like that's what's super
funny it might be a bad strategy for
jenna to play these characters against a
guy like 108 that has you know developed
a lot there's a lot of uh these
characters taking the past so
all right yeah i think if you look back
way back in the tapes one of the first
tournaments where he actually beat
subatomic sabers it was send cal
standoff and jonathan was playing yamcha
and vegito and their each into the
confirm from the top rope blue goku
going to bring the heat jonathan 10a
with a 50 50.
i don't think you pick the right team
hook killer everything working out right
now for 10a okay
right here and let me tell you
that was wild that was he tried to
change
okay so let's see here jill's like
sparking pressure by the way ridiculous
but i'm not gonna get a chance to see it
here because it did rare off let's go
jonathan telly right now trying to find
that hit on yamcha who a lot of people
right now are saying might be the worst
character in the game yeah it's rough
but you know sometimes you gotta you
gotta try to say it i can beat you with
my number one team but i've been playing
finally yamcha is where he should be in
a game like this like
okay hey he's pretty strong for a human
okay he's pretty strong for a human
okay here we go bringing it down
wow that was so hard that was so hard
i haven't heard that in a very long time
goodbye okay
so first character down there johnson
does still have spark available he's got
a demon in the back so that's when the
real game starts yeah and the thing
about jonathan too is everybody says the
game doesn't start against him until you
get to win probably but the 2m to emco
he may have blue hair but he still has
pogo i mean that's what we saw in the
nationals right like jonathan tenney
oh my goodness
oh here we go
oh wow
that's cheap the simple stuff dropping
for a reset jill is getting greedy
no no no no you don't get you don't want
to get greedy against jonathan yeah my
man is here to win he will not take any
hesitation to punish and this is such a
good lead for jonathan right now in this
first game
[Music]
right there that newly buffed larry of
course super good oh
it hurts he's not dead but that is a lot
of damage oh no another drop from julep
maybe pretty nervous yeah
i don't know how much he's been he's
been playing this team you know oh
busting out here we go
yeah but the bardock is a mainstay the
entire time so yeah that's true no
excuse there level three what's so funny
big man
yeah three here big boy broly in there
let's see this bottle has to defend
successfully jill i just trying to find
any kind of way out and of course it's
the lariat yeah it still has jello
[Music]
okay just chilling right now keep glass
on deck here big boy ah too much blocks
holding north right
there do it again just do it again look
who you got left though
listen this is a bit of a mismatch right
now we've got rolly versus
really hard what are you going to do
what are you going to do
oh he got it you better go back to
baseball because you're not doing well
in the fighting game
[Music]
my word he has awoken he let it go he
listened to android 16.
oh
this is so scary too i mean this is
going to be rough because like you've
got that whole sparkle it's not your
turn tila it's okay it's okay
it's okay
it's okay you know you know this journey
does hurt a lot because the guy that was
talking that talk as well he said i'm
gonna put them in their place and guess
what your place is the dirt right now
chiller first game jonathan tenney
against jilla let's go usa let's go you
are still in this guy's like 10 8 really
showing up right now jonathan oh oh okay
we got some weight
hey when i said sage when sage was like
jonathan you're going last
that was that was the tech we didn't
know we didn't know he knew he's like oh
sage went upstairs he drank the sacred
water
he met the supreme kai the elder kai
elder kai went like this and it's like
you have returned to your former glory
like matt said the the sacred ointment
yeah yeah
the forbidden one all right so
you got the power up it's the sacrifice
you got the power up from that but um oh
man you really said that
we're good we're good
okay but right now let's see let's see
if he's gonna have to uh
switch it up here let's see if he goes
for a different team could that be what
kind of said to him did he say
bro
yes he did he said
away from the screen put him in the
trash i don't want to see that human
anywhere on the screen and remember what
i said the americans have been having a
hard time with the bgo a assist not
vegeta himself on point so putting it
back in the anchor i like that because
you get the assist back on deck and
jonathan i don't know
oh my head yo the heel to the dome right
there and don't get this so this is the
team that we saw jilla achieve success
with yesterday second place in that
stacked 16-man bracket with 16 to the
best in the world
the next shoulder though gets the corner
back from uh for jonathan did you see
the way he punished that too the
overhead kick came from gogeta he
reflects goes for the kiba smokes both
assists but ah so good you want to talk
about switching sides with the ex right
there gogeta super saiyan 4 bro
how much damage is he building with this
no
wow
[Music]
listen king of the jungle monkey d jilla
that's that's his name on twitter right
look he loves it
monkey
he's out here bro
oh that was so that's how you beat the
hey assistant he's so smart i mean
i want to talk about smart right now
let's check out the hit characters
getting opened up getting blessed
okay double overhead good blocks here
though 108 just trying to defend and his
defenses actually look really impressive
in the couple so far
[Music]
there's an accident i promise
that's on purpose
and now a sea bully
is going to be left alone
this is jonathan's best character
yeah it is and you know it's like we're
talking about man this is where it
really kicks off and i'm looking over
there at that couch and bro it's like
i'm seeing a slumped nitro i'm seeing
clouds leaning over not looking not
looking so happy right now
[Music]
nice blocks
jonathan's not getting cracked and he
jumped the command grab my man is
reacting yeah good stuff there this man
could recognize her come on grip oh yo
using that projectile invincibility that
was so smart that's the counter play
that's dirty that's smart paulie quality
does not
does not have a good time against uh
he wanted the command grab
okay oh yo
this is gonna be a lot of damage a lot
of extension he's gonna build so much
bar too
oh great no he drops
what wait what he took him out
the challenge though from jonathan it
begins
bro
you you've got you don't have enough
armor on that one not enough armor for
the amount of buttons that jill is going
to press okay that's right she looking
to press those buttons king of the
jungle the zookeeper himself one one on
the board jilla
coming back resoundingly with this
gojita four one of the strongest
characters in the game especially of
dealing with these like very strong
neutral key blasts making broly not
looking as strong you just punch right
through the other side yeah it's hard
it's hard to deal with but going back in
no change on the side of jonathan this
is do or die for the us team for this
first set you two words it is indeed
guys this could be it the hopes that the
winning the first set might be out the
window right now for for the us heroes
but let's find out
okay
right now
[Music]
a high low he's playing he's playing a
left right game in a high low work
wow he tried to wake up teleport
maybe it might have been i don't know
what it was oh but he gets the hit
against the confirm this should be good
yep tell him
oh he keeps him in jonathan save your
health oh
bro that wasn't even two weeks that was
auto combo
just
he was doing it full screen gesture
things and this is the kind of play that
you really have to adapt to and it's so
hard
like because he just throws everything
at you let's go okay he's in there not
afraid to press buttons you cannot
condition he's going to continue to make
the decision he's going to make the
jonathan
fighting back you have a 50 50 here
jilla has sparking are you confident
enough to block this steward
let's find out see
i've seen a lot of solid defense against
that 21 okie today
man was staring at him giving him the
evils oh no the false sense of security
where's the button calls
and that's something you're punishing
the thing the french players do is they
punish your reactions you call something
that's gonna catch them in this trap
they lay the trap and the americans
always fall for it
it's looking true man it's looking like
it's gonna go down
the way the french guys planned it but
10a is not out of this by a long shot
he's still got that extremely solid
broly in the back this uh this blue as
well
this is scary
great jump on the lawn for the plus
frames
okay and of course this is a character
that a lot of people didn't believe was
a was a viable contender super saiyan 4
is a threat guys
what an auto combo
what an auto combo
oh
the frenchman okay here we go
that was smart jonathan with a match
adaptations from jonathan like he knew
that's exactly what jila wanted in that
situation
really bringing that camera
all the glitch oh no oh
you're really too hot jonathan oh my
goodness that glitch he's dead
oh no he dropped it but i'm jonathan
what are you expecting to not press
buttons come on
[Music]
broly on anchor
okay
with two characters still probably would
have been dead i mean not volleyball
would have been dead this is going to be
very hard for jonathan it is entirely
doable though one of the best anchors in
the game gets made on the key blast give
me bardock yeah he wants to take out
that assist he wants to take out the
character
oh my goodness look and what's part
gonna do here this is a matchup that
jonathan looks very comfortable playing
he is chilling big chilling right now
oh no he got a little too greedy he went
for the jump key blast excellent timing
on that super dash
this is rough
level three
if there's one thing that jonathan can
do it's block and this is where it's
going to be most important jonathan nice
reflect
look at him that's god this might be it
wait wait a minute
you gotta wait
don't curse anything
he's going to keep it simple that is
going to be gt france is going to take
the first set jonathan not strong enough
to finish it off
and it's going to be five
man
wow five
five two five two five two right there
france looking just super super strong
um man wow us
i mean we should we saw some signs of
life right like these guys obviously
here for a reason representing their
region looking very very strong but guys
we got we got full house we got a full
cami house right now we're back with the
boys
talk to us fearless because you were
watching the games from from the bench
what's the energy like up there what
were you saying honestly i missed this
turret yes
my room is buzzing everyone is jumping
around manchester up i mean you heard us
man acoustics have been having some
friendly pants you know discussion but
it was an entertaining thing it is it's
definitely been a lot of entertaining
set so far
uh it's interesting seeing the the
players that uh
adjust so far right a bit quieter than
usual i've got to say but carry on
finish
please finish
you already chose violence with me come
on all right
i'm saying that energy kind of different
right now
when he's on commentary i'm going to do
peace
i had a treaty
but you chose the violence
you're right you know you are not a fan
i mean we got a school board right here
scoreboard right there guys i i must say
something i'm i'm quite happy about one
thing about this set right which is i
think the players who we did not expect
to do well jonathan did great jonathan
obviously ridiculously upset that the
i want to say who got who got the two
wins
jonathan
and nitro and we're also going to be
welcoming the champion of the winning
team jilla to talk about how france
dismantled the rest of our team make it
let's get it
the the king of the jungle himself
i'll start with one question because
i've just asked this
were you surprised by jonathan tenney
to be honest uh in the beginning when he
a few a few days ago
he was just entering
the first
weekly tournament
named pfl and i was seeing him
on offline tournament and was like uh
he's not strong as he was on the
national relationship championship and i
was talking with him
what's wrong
with you or something like that and i
was like um it's a distress or something
like that he was telling me uh
because it's my first i think it was one
of his first tournament offline and he
don't really manage the stress that's
why he's uh
being some i think
being a
standard mod then he was on the national
championship and that was that's why i
think he was really really passive
on his gameplay and today she just
showed it to us so she was really strong
i was really really surprised he's the
the man i was really really surprised i
was like oh it's okay he's strong he's
strong i don't agree and just under
underestimate my enemy but it's okay he
will be okay he won't he won't beat
kaiden but uh
justin
i just is a really really surprised and
uh
it's good it's good yeah
so jilla
how does it feel to be the king how does
it feel to be the king right now
just like your hero just like your hero
how does it feel to be the king um
uh actually right now i have already
beat every french top player
right now i i already beat uh wawa
kaiden wade
yasha kane right now and noka etc we
have a lot of name
actually but i'm very happy and proud of
what i have done this weekend to be
honest i'm proud of you thank you
chiller
that was the question from gusting
i would like to say
your square button is very strong
if you would ever like to join the
square one society honorary remember
honorary remember
uh i just i just talking with eric
tomoko i just said i need a character
who what can press every time lll do you
know and
she just created me gogeta cg4 and i
just praise her very much thank you
of my heart and
this guy gt
[Laughter]
thanks to the gt commission i appreciate
it and uh
super the the fun of super [ __ ] it
all right so um so one other thing i
have before we go into the break guys
would be uh jilla so how do you guys
feel now obviously there's gonna be
another set coming up now how do you
feel about this one you're gonna play it
a bit differently different strategy
perhaps different lineup like you know
i'm sure we're going to see that later
on but like just tell us your thought
process going into that to be honest uh
we are all chilling actually but uh i
don't think we will change the
the team changes and uh i think we could
just continue the same the same thing uh
uh i think we will go for for for yasha
in first and uh
just adapted the cent the same strategy
yeah right now and uh just be lucky in
the in every ft2 okay all right and uh
one other thing as well just before we
quickly change here uh would be what was
it the yamcha pick was that just a
throwback to your like original team
yeah uh i was playing with a cloud
two two days ago and i was playing every
team uh cg4 my old team and uh
my ulti was good against him but i
wanted to try this team against jonathan
i haven't played with this team yet and
i was a bit uh
i wasn't a bit stressed about about that
team i wanted just to try how he can
manage his stress and his gameplay
against me with that team and uh i just
know
not the
the matchup of yamcha and i was like
okay you know i would just
go back for for the monkey king
the monkey king that's like
and i was like um in the beginning um
he know the
he was ready for the from for my team i
wanted to surprise him a bit to play my
mahal team that's why i just played that
team in first before the gojita team
makes sense that's what i like to hear
and the funny information that you
probably didn't know is that jonathan
played all of the oh actually two of
those characters before he was a yamcha
vegito player so when you picked that i
was like oh no
doesn't know but but what we do know is
that we have even more dragon ball
action coming up set two is going to be
on the way we're gonna be having
damascus and the one and only acoustics
on the mic for the future but give us
just a short moment we will be back soon
set two is on the way and america is
gonna make it a set three we'll see you
then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the dragon ball fighterz
world championship opening event i
freaking love this music is such a good
part i build up music
every time
that's going great right now and we are
back here for the france versus usa
exhibition
5v5
all right it's been a lot of fun so far
it's been an amazing weekend i can't lie
i've been struggling to not lose my
voice it's traditional always lose my
voice at offline events but i forgot
what offline events were because these
are release ancient weeks of the past
but we're currently living history uh
amazing then yesterday an amazing first
set but of course this is far from being
done because this
5v5 works in two sets you need to win
all five interviews all five of the of
one team twice france won the first set
five two
and now there's second sets which can be
the redemption set but also can be the
this was all our information
you know we got data from the first set
and america could very much come down
with this and the especially the special
thing with this is
team battles acoustics we we are used to
single tournaments a team battle is
completely different in terms of nerves
absolutely when you enter a team battle
obviously you know you're playing right
now you playing for your country playing
full of rivalry and everything but
there's also something when you're
playing and your boys are behind and you
know you can't let them down you know
there's an extra extra weight on your
shoulders and we've seen some players
excelled in this environment some
players kind of cracked a lot of nerves
and and that that like is a huge factor
yep
uh absolutely especially like i think we
can say something
our mvp is jonathan tennant right
my mans
my fans took those nerves and turned it
into straight skills yep all right if
anything people say okay america we lost
five to this person but guess what
it's merely the download
needed some information
and and now we gonna come back
i think i think a lot of people did
better than people expected them
especially cloud and tenant yeah they
did really amazing right and france is
throwing off some strength i'm gonna put
some respect on him i'm gonna put some
mix on your name
i appreciate the blessing but you know
what guys we are ready for the second
set of the day we're gonna throw back to
reza on the stage because the captains
are about to tell us who to get because
because we go back to the beginning of
the set it's a blind pick
so we're gonna discover who is gonna be
the first match of the second set reza
take it away who do we got thank you
damascus thank you acoustics the france
is leading up 1-0 but first of all
welcome back to the dragon ball fighterz
world championship exhibition guys it's
a five versus five tournament france
versus america it's one all right now
for the french players i might have some
word maybe from sage what did you think
about all first set
fiji's
b d's
that's the world jilla
what's up
what's up that's it guys so the second
question as usual who's going to be the
first pick for you guys
my french adiron brother aka
i see what you're trying to do now okay
kane is going first for the french crew
sage
out again
cloud again eight or five that's your
turn my man
it's your time bro anyway okay let's go
guys let's get back to damascus and
acoustic oliva
all right all right america keeping the
same strategy of sending cloud first
yeah friends going from kane what i'm
gonna expect obviously we haven't heard
what's happening in teams but i'm gonna
expect he's on friends side kane was
like i want to play guys you know i
haven't played i wanna i wanna be the
one to lead the team right now and cloud
was probably like i would have redeemed
myself i was that close for winning i
should have i could have won earlier so
i'm gonna i'm gonna try and make it
happen right now i i definitely think it
was kane wanting to play because when
jill was on the bench with us he did
talk about uh keeping the order the same
i think uh he had to give in to cain's
uh kane's work was like come on man
i want some fun too yeah so i want to
get in the mix yeah let me get my
touches coach take me off the bench i i
completely understand so the question is
okay
[Music]
i see super broly on the screen super
rolling is he gonna play the super
policy no goodness games got a solid
super broly team the players are ready
we're ready for game number one razer
are we ready oh
for sure that my skills we're ready man
all right let's get it
set
let's go let's go
all right i have peeped a super broly on
the screen
and i think i think i'm not i think i
think
i think i'm not lying
guys
set number two the first set went to
france 5-2 this is redemption set for
america or confirmation set for friends
the first game about to be decided all
for us to tube and remember we're
playing the winner stations for format
so kane plays the super bullet team team
gohan super broly and trunks oh
nice gonna get him with the
anti-reflection he's gonna get a full
cover from this
oh look at the meter
yeah i need the wheels
three three bars
so much oh
that was all right
we're on the coming house this is summer
take the shirt out guns out you've been
going to the gym shorts
why did he get three bars in less than
20 seconds because he needs it
all right
nice this is literally it's been 30
seconds it's just two cars oh mix time
all right nice and we're going for the
combo that doesn't drop which is the
best common simple bnb
all right we're going to get kim out of
here yeah definitely
nice and this gogeta is actually a
recent make from cloud
he's been influenced by the french i'm
definitely like you know what the the
text the tech is being absorbed yes all
weekend and cloud has ascended to the
gojita
plane of existence right now
all right looks like that's smart early
interesting oh but get hit by two three
success this camera's gonna do so much
violence in the corner
okay he's gonna go for the simple one
and straight to level three goes for tin
gohan he's got sports we can do like he
jump into a dash oh no spark is out
spark is out so the mix cannot happen
gets away from the sport gets away from
the assistance as well
nice
oh almost got him with the bomb
all right and kate is so good with these
air tight ears especially
he's dead
he's got two assists yeah well acoustic
let me teach you something when you do
comments with overcame you never say
he's dead you say he might die he might
know he's notorious for the combo drops
he's like you never know if you're
getting king combos okay lost combos so
as an experience kane commentator i now
use him my tie
we don't we don't we don't lie out there
we don't take risks so only yourself
speaks in absolutes
okay
all right
number one
it's a level one yep
all right right now cloud is down to his
last character this is ui goku though
five meters on deck makes that happen
protagonist oh six six seven oh no what
was that so i think that was the king uh
oh yeah seven meters oh we're going to
make this hurt
okay
[Music]
to level three very
good all right he could waste a meter
here
and get the he could get the left right
mix yeah he can just ex dash he's gonna
go for the meaty five out
or we could just nothing ahead kane just
back dash there oh
kane was trying to press bottoms landing
clouds
taking one down all right two to go oh
look this is possible now he just got it
he got his he has to discipline his
child now
sometimes spam the rods for the child
oh there it is okay
okay get the side switch with the
autocombo
stock down time
okay you're gonna respect the ui goku
yeah but we also have to respect the
character oh no
oh no clouds working his way towards a
comeback did you see how low that was
that was low aidan right in the
guys don't try this at home this is a
dangerous play
i try to stomp the man
all
right
how much can you do from this game if
you do not drop that combo that assists
being regenerating right now extend
you've got tin one behind go for this
level one
all right hold on
into level three chris chris
that is a nice one but he's not dead
what touchy we have one chance
one touch
one touchy indeed nice one from kane
i think he was starting to feel the
stress because cloud was looking good
without you i goku but he manages to
take game number one
that's super broly i'm happy when i see
super bullies i know you know it's not a
we call them dominican rolling dominican
brother
dominican brother is the one
look he works on his upper body all the
time he takes his shirt off when it gets
hot yeah
he probably uh he probably wears those
extra medium t-shirts oh my goodness
medium
they're too small to really be like
it's not a small but it's an extra
medium exactly it's the one to make sure
that you can see absolutely everything
through it all right the pressure now
this part cloud forced to block how's
the [ __ ] mix
all right luckily that spark is out now
so this is a chance for cloud kane using
that spark early is really good for him
all right
here's his assist back oh and we taking
the shirt off already guess puppy
no more extra medium i'm on the beach
this time the coming house is there
[Applause]
the combo is probably going to be longer
than the entire spark right it is super
brilliant
from the
[Music]
hold up he can kill here level one
one two and three yeah it's a level two
actually can you just one behind this we
don't we're not taking it anymore yeah
we're gonna listen one would have killed
anyway
you got money
spend it exactly but it's going to come
back anyway don't do this
we need to win this set yeah we need to
win
we're not taking any risks we're not
we're not saving any medium yeah if it
kills if it can we use it the meter will
come back is dragon ball you know it's
never too far just you just walk forward
a couple
mix oh yeah
oh i don't know
[Music]
why is he about to have seven
six and a half six and a half oh
just kidding
he used to i don't know how long he's
been since he played the trunk oh no oh
my god let's go
active defense wake up five lll
square bone society guys is
international doesn't matter if it's
america yeah does it matter if we're in
france
square one works exactly
nice right now kane is working on
he's going oh no conversion oh it's
gonna get some more pressure
[Music]
what about with level two until level
one now
oh he has level two now yes i forgot
yeah i know
see me i'm always uh i always try to be
uh
as efficient as possible
so if i can waste more meter to kill you
i always will find a way
yes and that's a great one
oh no
wait huh
number one it's a lot more
i did yes
taking the lead it's a 19 gohan but both
of cloud character are in one touch
situation
i think tinker can literally sneeze on
them and kill both of these characters
right oh yeah yeah
respect social distancing right now
against the 33 meters
jumping around trying to go for the legs
and another one that is a dead kid with
the 1v1 cloud playing his tournament
life right now all right
all right one touch on both
sides oh
don't do
this punish all right he's not destroyed
i like the bomb coming
oh we are well free oh just reflect we
can get some more no
last game
staircase
inside i did not convert
there's still one touch we've got a ton
of time is running away
sometimes you don't need mix you don't
need anything you just do the thing i
mean let's be real yeah this like this
is the dumbest thing to do in this
situation right because if you're
mashing or anything but that's the thing
that they've tried so much by solid play
they're coming to the stupid play right
now because you're like
he had he had more than three meters he
has a six frame jack that could have
anti-air into six seven anything
i'm gonna do six seven
i'm gonna do six seven i i respect that
sometimes you know it's just this like
you know that this is the one thing he's
not looking for he's actively looking
for dragon rush you know after this so
he's really really trying to look for
that dragon rash to attack everything
and that was the one option you forgot
kane taking the first game over cloud
and
that's the moment now for america who do
you sense do you want to
stop
kane's uh momentum
because at the moment remember france
won the first set this is still set
number two
first game two nil from cambridge again
gg is too cloud like um
once again two games were extremely
close unfortunately that dominican
probability was a bit too uh
we had so sad it was it was a bit two
times this is the current score of
course clouds currently out for the set
if he wants a chance to play a game he
needs his boys to uh save america and
win that second set if i'm the captain
right
i think i'm sending in john jonathan's
hot right now from the previous set
really good
and then i feel that if they pick
someone else after him if jonathan could
keep that momentum you can take two
right and that's the important thing you
want to take as many people out in a row
especially when you're under right now
in a team battle and you have to use the
player's emotions yeah so right now john
be kind well that's that's strong well
we've got the players ready because we
got sage ready to tell brazil
who's next
to both players on the right side as
usual cloud did good but at the end of
at the end of the day kane was better he
pulled out the broly super team that
nobody plays in this room
what do you think you can do against it
dominican broly
is pretty strong
but now it is time for me to step up and
attempt to defeat it
oh [ __ ] so the captain is jumping in
probably when i have a z brodie that's a
super brody anyway it's time to fight on
the left side kane on the right side for
the for the american team stage
damascus acoustics it's on you guys all
right
that's gonna be the battle of the pecks
i i'll be honest zebra only has a higher
credit score than uh the ass brother so
he's just gonna win
i don't know zebra lee starts without
the shirt he's zebras he probably starts
at one hundred percent starts about a
shirt right yeah well he stands tall
back straight he does
he does that's the one we're gonna see
the temperature because remember guys
the rule as well is you can only change
team after a loss so kane has to keep
that superb team right now and that
might be you know that's part of the
strategy as well you're like okay who is
confident to beat that super bully team
down because even even if he's gonna
change to another team well you already
wanna you already one more game yeah
that's all you need so let's uh let's
see what sage is cooking for us probably
a zebra against uh oh yeah super broly
you know like the
original irrelevant broly now you know
but let's go back to raza to throw the
game
ready
we're ready to go
stage ready
kane ready go go my friend let's get it
boys university party keep
[Applause]
sage has a lot to uh to do right now you
know he's one of uh one of the potential
saviors and we've seen how strong kane
was yesterday as well kane was playing
at the level yes they have rarely seen
him at that level the american team is
going to look forward to see how uh yeah
yes they came but wawa and
and nitro and losers yep that's ot yep
who goes yeah i just entered the
tournament how'd you do yeah put i put
wow and nitro loses that's all right
the opening gambit
goes for sage dashing to get close to
the corner
oh
they get it
happy birthday
nice
i like that he's chasing the uptick and
then covering downtime because this yeah
kane's still getting away though oh yeah
full screen neutral nice [ __ ]
how do i catching him
kane staying full screen i don't think
i've ever seen these two fights actually
even back in season two let's go
pressure
that's not true from a level three
yeah he's not gonna spawn just yet and
now he does that's good
into the reflect that's this is their
mix no no three
three overheads three overheads it's
dangerous
all right nice get the knock down
i'll mix him
oh that's that that's that dv is this
buff right there yeah
all right guess the extension we jump as
well
it's so sweet
why do you have this reach up
that yell goes high man
no but
yeah and look at the team chemistry as
well that's all the corners so you get
the trucks mixed behind this side oh he
missed the flip he missed the input if
you see trunks doing five h after this
is because they missed the flip on this
and now he's gonna extend as much as he
can that should be enough to get the
kill over the base vegeta
oh yeah
he wants to put rolly back and that's
gonna be the battle
of the pekka what what
is chess day chestnut what day was it
yesterday
chestnut chest day exactly
every day every day
we never do legs it's only chest day
massive pectoral muscles live on stream
look at that
i mean it's nine foot or muscle
we have actually uh calculated something
on my stream it would take 12 12 gt goku
to make one zebra it would take 12 years
it
[Music]
starting to be good to be putting a lot
of pressure on kane kane blocking in the
corner this tiger is going to work i
think kane was trying to jump right
there that chicken blocking is going to
get your chicken cooked
oh three minutes oh
dragon rush
oh level one
one character away from
taking the first game and potentially
forcing kane to take another team i
think kane
did not want to face aid with that team
anyway but you know you pick that team
you need to roll with it
okay
i like the sage playing our new york
special the lame game
i love the lame game yep
they buff those key blocks because now
they're broadly level oh nice
he finally converted off of that you
know about time it took him a minute i
got to vanish yeah oh my god that's what
i do all right in the corner oh no
the classic
the classic it's not gonna be blocked
next oh he's dead
oh
we're gonna get the fourth meaning
number one
into level two into level three
and him
the l oh yeah gracefully he's like so
good he's the president it's uh
from from me to you respectfully
delivering the l and now that might push
kane into selecting another character so
he's doing doing the work
he's doing the work we're just starting
off sage doing the work taking the first
game so even if kane does switch
they still got one more game maybe yeah
you got one more game for downloading
and that's a professional wait let me
take all the guys so you see that's a
professional
an evil genius some would say
you strongly believe in that one i
strongly strongly believe in the one
game to win that's that really strongly
but i wonder who kane is about to pick
and you see kaiden coming last thing we
mentioned that yesterday right
one thing in france is everyone has a
billion teams yep and
having a billion teams
can be a uh a weakness especially in the
first two situations yeah because in the
first two you need your team to be 100
and when you have a lot of teams each
team is seventy percent
so you're gonna pick one you're gonna
set them against yourself it's back to
the team we've seen yesterday and what
is probably kane's main team right now
that's super saiyan for gogeta kefla and
janemba opens with the region okay and
that's very nice gonna get a solid
knockdown right here
doesn't have enough uh knockdown
advantage to do the talk though oh sage
is gonna spark
oh no
oh no
oh no because afraid of this character
please guys
thanks for next time as much as he can
the spark is about to run out that
should be enough wait hold on he's dead
into level one k flies in
and that base vegeta another quick work
you took an entire character in the
spark that is not good
oh try to command grab him but he's
going to get punished for it
all right going to use assists get a
full combo
oh get a full drop
[Music]
oh he tried to counter that guard so not
going to happen
he's going to catch you
please see assists
they exist
oh that's such a good [ __ ] for her from
combos
all right
that you know what that was that was the
sf5 shimmy
that was definitely the sf5 right there
that was another game live right now and
he
extending win one one one kill this team
i mean gojita's like non-powered up
level one it's not the best but that
should be enough that should be enough
into the number slice her up and get out
oh
all right it's sage down since just z
rolling no smart
actually you could have killed with
spark but that's okay we're just gonna
go for bombos that work putting man down
it goes with gogeta and that's what
that's what i've also liked about some
of the changes made this season is uh
especially with like i call it
the combo tag yeah you can use it to
give the other character the knockdown
advantage of another character
that is so good that is so good but that
was a
strong statement we're not going to talk
about that strong statement by kane
didn't lose a single character barely
worried in this one putting stage in
choppery again and
yeah that's a lot there's a lot riding
on stage right now because you you don't
want to build that momentum on k inside
i'll be honest i think after this like
our entire is gonna have trauma from
like gogeta
currently in europe he's definitely a
super saiyan for gogeta arc so we're
just all
surprised and the c assist is going to
allow the combo after the command
all right and all the way to the other
corner there's the assists
level three all right into the mix you
can get the fuzzy
dude
all right i'm gonna switch out vegeta
oh
decided to spark yeah
pick him up now put him down
now pick him back up
and then put him down
and then pull him down one more time
there we go
all right now this is actually really
good for say kane i honestly think
wasting that spark there and losing the
character for it
21 in the corner
oh no oh no kane oh yeah just change
things oh yes listen can you also make
up drops
[Music]
all right number one level three
you cannot reflect your number lmh is
antar reflection
you do lmh it's enter reflect
oh you reflect multiple times until he's
done with this oh no that was half
birthday on this but no spark of course
you can get one
all right it's next time i'm guessing
other side
[Music]
[Music]
down into level three to keep keep
flying kane looking good sending sage
the final character okay oh sorry
about to start the game apologize
now kane can make the comeback one more
time against
i apologize
all right oh yeah zoning
for for the
the original broly and the canon one
two h kane was a bit too ready put some
more pressure
anti jump is gonna be blocked there is
no assist
the guard can silvan is gonna be there
kane's gonna be blocking the corner
you've got to watch out for the command
grab all right 17 frames of fear oh no
[Music]
no oh he actually caught
you monster oh the hell did you convert
of this one he's gonna send him all the
way back to the corner yes
he's got the seat for the mix oh the
paint train that's gonna be punished and
kane getting the jh sending the kill
sage out that second set once again
starting absolutely perfectly for france
too to nil something needs to be done
acoustics all right something needs to
be done just put me in
there
they need they need the the laughter
they need the lava they need my nappa
something needs to be done right now you
need they need the domage
you need
to stop
gain right now
the confidence starting to build the
combos are starting to not drop yeah the
team is there
change team two nil overshaded with a
new team
all right you know what time it is right
natural time
it could be nitrogen at the time because
now we're stuck down we're down to nitro
yeah jonathan hook and god france with
the full team can't yet to lose listen
let me let me let me tell you what if i
was on the u.s side
i would send jonathan tenney because he
proved that he could be the very best he
beat kaiden earlier yeah i would keep
natural fourth and hook fifth
the reason for that
hook has a ton of experience hook is not
gonna crumble on the nerves sure you
know that if you put hook ankle
there is a be a bigger chance of him
popping off than if you put all that
pressure on nitro who have to remind you
guys first tournament of like abroad
yeah first time abroad like even outside
of tournament this first time like in
the foreign country first tournament
that's a lot of pressure do you want to
put the anchor role on nitro despite him
arguably in my opinion he's the
strongest player in this team he's the
one to lead the team
and you know what
diamonds are made under pressure
and i think
if we can put
honestly if i'm going to be honest this
is an ample time this is a perfect time
to put either nitro or jonathan under
pressure yeah to bring him to an even
higher level yeah i agree i agree today
today is we're all ascending but
we got sage there we're about to know
team america speak fresher who's next
welcome back to the mainstage ladies and
gentlemen sage i'm with you right now
you just had a great game against gabe
unfortunately you lost it who's going to
be next for your team and what do you
think is going to be the strategy from
now on
uh before i give us the next player i
just want to say
i did say that i could be friends
without practicing for a year right but
that was actually directed to kane so i
just want to say kane
kane
[Applause]
thank you thank you
we all appreciate this yes
uh so our next player is going to be our
best player nitro
let's go
nitro
on stage my man damascus acoustic what's
good
ah the run back from yesterday remember
kane beat nitrous today in the game
which means nitro has gained experience
now yes sending nitro and that's huge
statement right because if nitro falls
i can't lie
i love tiny and hook if nitro falls if
nature fails to stop kane
i don't think they're running through
all these five yeah i think nigel knight
once again nitro just came to paris was
here to live his best life and have fun
and what happened
he's got the weight of an entire country
on his shoulders i'm not sure you know
the story of atlas the titan holding up
earth on his shoulders that's nitro
right now holding up everything he's
like please
please please let's let's see let's see
how it goes that's a ton of pressure and
you know like i was talking to him like
between says because i was watching him
play earlier and he definitely when he
was when you know like when he was
putting his control down between set he
was like this which is normal but ask
him is it nerves or excitement and he
says i think it's excitement like i feel
okay but you know it's excitement that's
the enemy that's that's it that's the
enemy that i've watched enough animation
like this is when you power oh yeah when
you're back to the corner when you're
about to die you think about your mom
your child who's going to be drunk
let's go back to reza reza are we ready
yes we're ready but before that samad i
don't know if you do remember last year
we did that
team battle france versus europe
five versus five
and kane strikes the entire european
team
so i believe that if
kane takes this game it might be done
but i don't know anyway
nitro good luck kane good luck let's get
it boys that is true i i i remember that
i wasn't on razer stream so there was a
huge obviously always rivalries right
and and because the french tend to like
run
europe in terms of like like tournaments
and stuff europe was like nah nah if we
if we do all star against france like
europe is europe's good okay so they did
fight against europe
cool guys
like my friends didn't want to play i'm
just gonna always be for everyone i'm
gonna have fun
he's like what if this happens again
because kane right now is looking good
but he's about to play the big boy once
again he won yesterday over nitro can he
do the game
and nitro 4 going to 18 right going back
to the to the kickball 21 uh and a ui
goku team and for him i think this is
definitely more of a comfort thing right
uh he doesn't feel comfortable playing
18 against these guys since she is a
relatively new one for him
but nice good jump key boss
yep combo tag time
dragon rush get the knock down
we've activated full swear mode oh my
goodness that was mixed
that was actually mixed it's not
supposed to black kane is just extending
he's waiting for the sister this is like
oh yeah he's back
this defense doesn't meet the default oh
no
so you know that commenting the curse
thing right yeah uh that was so
unfortunate how that just happened at
the exact moment i said the d word
[Music]
acoustics mids listen we don't do mix
here we go that was zero on block that's
mix
that's me exactly thank you acoustics is
ascending
now i'm gonna start putting vegito oh
it's done it's time he's diving right
now nitro putting some pressure on that
genema and i must say i'm a general
player i strongly believe geneva
struggled against kiku i think and kane
agrees he was trying to get that genema
out as soon as possible but
oh no he dropped it
[Music]
over nitro putting some pressure into
the corner
what are we going to combo
i like to see assist there oh
he wanted to uh you know to charge
during the css right oh yeah be forced
to block block
i'm surprised he didn't try to level
through the second one
we don't take that here he's okay
right now level one into level one kane
making a strong statement nitro now is
down to ui goku he's got what three
seconds of spark remaining all right i
think kane didn't know which direction
golgi to hit him
[Music]
okay wait hold up this is nitro yeah
where you are go
the best you are oh nice look at that
i'll try ignorance don't touch not
trying this man
get tested don't touch me
you're not allowed in the studio without
a pcr
oh
it's white oh the chinese
gonna get away but that's not gonna be
enough to get anything
he's he's baiting he's painting
something but the two eight nitro
defeats the geneva trying to walk
towards the comeback listen you heard
him you heard of 2m correct yeah that's
too h
that is
it actually is i can't lie
level three
it's time for the mix mix gate all right
what do you got for us there's no mixing
there's no mix here what do you got for
us nothing guard console getaways
movement is moving nitro does a lot of
preemptive like this that's so good
because it stops the french from using
any of the travelling moves or the five
vanilla attempts oh there was no punish
right there there is that is only minus
five
no
it's not fair
[Music]
[Applause]
is looking absolutely dominant all right
listen
that's on the game one all right that's
game one
we're gonna we're gonna make our
comeback right now
this is our chance it's just game one
this is just game one
oh my goodness and we're already like
one oh my god okay okay
and look at that like i said nitro
already started off oh the gym heavy
so a lot of things i noticed that
we don't take those caden will [ __ ] you
now could i send kid boo down what's the
mix behind this tap tap we're gonna
assist we're just trying to reflect on
this one and another reflect great
defense
i think it caught right out of his jump
frames right there too uh staircase
combos
that was three steps
nice
oh we got 35 overheads that was that was
interesting
oh
i think that dragon rush was definitely
i think i think that was a level 1
he's done this earlier that's a drop
from nitro kane about to get a pickup no
nitro is about to try and get away
kane's
oh that was such a good reflection to
keep guys right there
all right go for the knockdown again we
got two assists set up
double jump again to play the five l or
reflect kane
okay okay
got to play late play is it 2s
all right
all right let it come to you they're as
close as this
all right we just playing neutral wow
frame dash watch out for those double
mediums please do not get here nigel
all right oh
nice good blocks
oh the dragon she was waiting for
something else he was not looking to
dragon rush okay looking that's not
gonna be much damage of course but
probably gonna put him down he's gonna
follow about three yes time for the
developer the candy cane oh look at the
candy i hate pepperoni do you want some
sugar oh this looks appetizing diabetic
please
[Music]
that's awesome
there's no reason to not smart in this
situation
[Music]
nope nope no spot yet he tried to bait
the chain is happy to block on this one
okay he's gonna block again oh the
dragon is gonna be good and that's the
misdirection classic right you call that
assistant look at that these dragons
oh yeah the misdirection classic has
been so strong it's even better against
strong players because they're reacting
to the assist coming rather than the dr
so beautiful
have you ever gotten mixed because you
were smart
you were just like oh i actually thought
so i so i lost
that's crazy that's how it is oh no
sorry let me let me just break this down
real quick right after the the 3h for
vegeta you have three options you have
multiple options you have the overhead
one you have to block standing you have
the low one of low and then you can do
five eight thing is like if you jump
back you block the overhead and you
block the low as well if you jump back
the five h cut catches the jumper that's
why you just saw that five ferris
landing is because nigel was holding her
back expecting an overhead or something
else
i i i usually go for the fourth option
which is uh i like to just do 5s and
then look at someone reflect
i like this
there are plenty of ways to pay the
potential jumper back jump yeah right
he's gonna wait right now
he's gonna get caught shout out to 21
covering
all right
it's knocked down time
please
[Applause]
nitro has been trying to bait that spot
so hard it's only over time
nice
yeah gets away nice one
one character away from sending nitro
out if i'm correct isn't it like 24 25
it's it's it's like 24.
okay oh yeah
right
[Applause]
one touchy
mix
up three
the potential savior is out
he's looking long for man
long
length
[Music]
extension
the distance
listen
this is the time of the movie
where the underdogs make their comeback
now
all right
we're down
to hook and god
and jonathan tenney
the only two left a lot
the last americans in france
still have a full team
they got yasha
wawa
kaiden kane angela
cain's still up
chad keep pressing mix although the shot
is full of me
let me they're still saying can i get my
toxicity take the better of me do it
if i see any of you guys
right i run a weekly every tuesday on my
stream it's called wanted
it's a king of the hill series
there's only been seven champions in
history five of them are the french team
and every week do you know what happens
on my stream questions what happens
stream monsters come uh-huh is good but
the guys in america or the hmz or nitro
they would come and run that set
they would be there and if you come to
my chat and write these words
i'm clicking on ban
indefinitely i'm not even entertaining
this talk anymore the receipts are being
created here
the gaming is there
dragon ball fighterz
is flying on its way to france
the rivalry is really there but kane
look at this there is one name on the
right because you made one y'all made
more data why would y'all do this
production no
production take that off
no
you know what i heard one day on an
american stream what did you hear do you
know what i heard what did you hear i
heard oh yeah why why is the problem
everyone knows that
what one hasn't even played
he hasn't even laid his hands on his
stick
he's chilling he's got a new sponsor
he's got a new dream he's got a bms
shirt he's representing an esports team
he literally he hasn't even played
in casey i wonder if i just got a new
sponsor last night we won't even see bms
i love you guys but we won't even see
your boy
we might not even see your boy
look at this he's chilling he's just
tweeting like yeah so mom look at the
sponsor that looks nice on the stream
look how nice wawa looks man we left we
left like we left season two he was a
kid we come back standards got three
kids he's playing child support
listen america
america
this is an office
america
america this isn't over reza what do you
got for us man i'm gonna die yeah i'm
sorry some adverts you know he was just
walking on the stream man no one can do
that bro but no disrespect to the player
man they're really happy to be here
they're fighting for us
it's more of
a twist chat problem right but anyway
stage
you've got two players left in your team
ken is still there
a streak of three wins
tell me something i don't know
all right i'm gonna send that hook
okay hook is coming it's got the beige
jetta piccolo zebraly shell so it's
going to be dangerous you can see it
there thank you very much sage
samad
back to you bro
all right
let us not just
rule america out just yet
listen all right like i said earlier
it's not over
to the fat lady sings
and my mom is still
home love you mom we made it to paris
we mean
may we
[Music]
may we
may we
oh my god
all right so we got
we got a huge weight again you know like
hook
hook has saved america more than once
before right we all remember the summit
cook has won in france before ufa yeah
he was the one in grand finals he lost
to goichi but he reset the bracket
and he played like crazy
raza
other players ready yes man i might need
some hype in this room please guys
anyway
gang guys on the right side katie's on
the left side let's get it boys
[Applause]
[Music]
oh now we get the lights when we're down
le boo i'm giving it a label
listen
listen we even you know a whole lot of
french teams at home
we even were nice enough to give the
player one side to the usa right
so you can kind of feel like at home you
know you play i request a sign switch
guys guys we have to check request a
side switch
ruin the momentum
quick quick quick
all right let's see though let's see
kane versus who gengar hook one of the
most experienced players in the entire
room right now can he bring something
for the american team
all right definitely i think hook's team
is very good it's it's similar to the
ideology a lot of french players have of
like just controlling neutral with your
assists and then using your characters
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what is happening
guys please
i can't pop up for us if we don't win
oh
oh he dropped it though
oh i must go what my planet needs me
i'm out i don't want to play here who
gets to pick up and who can go is
absolutely melting there's a solo picot
all right hold on hold on the piglet was
smart technically
smart times froze when he got the
cowboys so this could still be possible
he's got spark the kanji is going to
wait
you know that orb is good but you got
your two eyes out geneva so you can act
you meant to say you meant to say 2m you
were talking about 2 2s you met why do i
need 2 2 s when you get a journal
wait gonna get the extension level 1
into level 1.
[Applause]
all right match two hook already started
it let me get a point
all right knock down let's go we
fighting back hit him with the mix oh
look at that high low he didn't watch
his toes
oh it's luke tom what's america's
favorite cereal
sending him closer to the corner dashing
in into the moon jump the sixth stage
gonna be blocked hook is forced to block
right now he's got spark there's nothing
oh no
mix
please guys just mash on them instead
don't reflect match on them please
it'll work i promise
okay level three
oh ab close sometime
let's see
candy cane peppermint pudding
oh
to find any kind of answer oh hold on we
can still make this come back this is
broly the zebraly and piccolo one of the
strawberry sauce this season
nice the good hair there let's get it
started all right we're gonna go for the
ex i like to knock down level three
gk demon elbow left to right higher low
oh my god he blocked that oh
okay let's get this knocked down that's
death
level one
into level one
get done
okay
all right
zebra lee piccolo
what's smart
i believe
what are you doing don't touch me i
don't like to be touched
oh okay
okay okay
okay where are you going
oh this guy's belong to him right now
there's an assistant all right
don't do that
don't do that
don't do it as big man that's big me and
bro
this channel
choo choos bro oh the mix mix
mixed
good six this was a mix
he got mixed my physics mix
kind of erases the keep last game from
zebra right now graduating making it a
race to h no we cannot
all right oh
oh
oh like that dragon rush come here grab
all right it's open oh yeah i like this
even more damage oh grab him again oh
yeah oh it's set up
straight to spark he blocked him
oh no he's like he's alive he's like
he's he's not he's not like yeah
all right i guess
did i lie actually oh
oh we just showed up now i like that oh
oh it's a bloody level one
that
yeah
yeah
yeah i will say this french players
constantly communicating talking to the
players coaching i would like to see
some more of that from the us
they've yet to coach and sing one of the
players aren't they
yeah guys there is coaching aloud it's a
team tournament team tournament is all
about the team spirits
let's go another game
i like the spirit right now the spirit
of getting hit
oh nice good tank
oh that was a misinform
oh no nice one yep
we learned that from the french
uh
uh oh the loops oh the setup what
my goodness what a super dash
all right dragon rush to get the sliding
knock down what's the next move
match on them mash
oh
great one to get away from the piccolo
assist got to watch out it's the
berserker battle right now
just waiting great reflection
stop that don't stop dashing on me i
like it
i get scared when people dash for me
i can't see i can't see anything i have
no idea what's happening acoustic you
know what's happening
mix is happening
okay
oh the dumpling
[Music]
nice
excellent defense by him
i like that he did the slow level one
and they didn't figure those other one
oh
they're getting killed
are we out
we're escaping we're smoothing oh no
pizza delivery for a cane
a pizza delivery for kane if you would
it's okay uh-huh oh i think oh
we are we having
is zombie hook here uh-huh this is
somehow is that hulk
this is hook former panda is it
format
electronically c
c c c
uh-huh oh oh
uh-huh and then look at this if you
continue afterwards we don't even need
to continue
we don't need to continue afterwards
listen kane you caused a lot of pain
but if you think you're being hooked
you're insane
it's done
oh look at that zoning neutral ah the
americans oh oh yeah that's how america
plays we're lame we're lame we don't
want you to get in oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
[Applause]
okay
no
no
what are we doing no oh oh let's go
opening that's a dead base vegeta yes
one down two to go okay level one
a little ugly rocks look at this
[Applause]
all right
all right
we still have and i said it before this
show oh no oh nice stop
thank you thank you thank you brother
ggs oh ggs
oh
here's a present for you
before we go here's another
nice one
i can't black
last one i'm telling you hook
i will never underestimate hook's clutch
potential oh yeah hook in clutch form
is like
i mean we've just seen it he just
stopped kane's role
but it's like i mean he just has to go
through
way too much let me be real
if i'm friends
just for the lord
just for the culture i'm sending jina
i play for the love of god please
for friends and hook is in his moment he
needs to take as many people down as
possible let's go back to reza are we
sending jilareza all right let's go huck
i don't know i don't know i don't know
i'm not the captain of the team right
i've got you on the left side hook did
super good because kane is actually a
dsl so every game he wins
he's becoming better you know right
just lose to hook getting good dj's mate
what's the next move
of that uh ggs to look uh
i think the next one would be
me
no i'm joking
no i guess it's time i will put the kick
of the line okay whoa whoa
[Applause]
how am i set
what will we play boys what's good go
stick
dumb excuse
yeah i think y'all put the nail on the
coffin on us right because you put a
wawa but think of this
they lose the wawa right now
how far does the morale drop
so it's kind of man the world doesn't
drop they're excited behind i'm just
saying
genuinely right the one of the strength
is that i can't think of one person who
is the anchor in that team like you know
that's thing but regardless you're right
he's still the leader and the king he's
finally about you know actually really
happy will get that because i really
wanted to watch hook up because i don't
think they've ever played since since
like hook stopped competing in that
season two and wawa started to pop off
and like go around so i would really
like i really wanted to see a set
between hook and wawa we're about to
have it and now the eternal question
the the roulette is turning you know for
the characters oh yes
the question
that's what happens i think the gimmick
team is coming out
never take hook lightly
never had to take relationships let's go
back to razer other players ready
all ready why were you ready hook
that's good boys let's get it guys it
has to be done right now huawei is on
stage for the first time in this 5v5
battle america supports your players
friends in europe portugal players
oliver
let's go
i've had some professors i've had so
much bad luck in paris please
all the luck that i didn't have to give
it to hook right now you won't know how
bad it's been for me you know now let me
let me be real quick to you know that
team from walmart it's probably my
favorite team to do commentary on in
this game because it's tim he's not even
sweat his team like
cooked like his team anytime he hits you
he's looking at you you're cooking
he's he's there cooks you like it's gold
vegeta level seven for those of you who
haven't seen yet
that team huawei plays a team that is
super saiyan for gogeta piccolo and
android 17. he plays piccolo and i win
17b which means any opening
from gogeta if it's an opening on the
ground gets five level ups if it's not
putting in the air gets about three
level ups which means
he will too touch you anytime or he will
just level up gojita put him out and
then you like kill your first character
and then bring back gogeta to shake your
hands so hands might be shaken
we might be like
come here but how ready
is hook we have seen wawa taking it
overnight for yesterday
with this one
let us see
bets are on on the chat chassis who is
newly signed by bms
french esports team
wow and that's all i guess with the
cheeky opening
all right we're going to get the first
knock down here uh that's the new and
improved knock down
mix mix
[Music]
oh dragon rush all right pick up
all right
it's going to go to him i've pants my
controller's broken i had a had an extra
fight
i'm going through it so much pain
make my pain worse and hook
nice if you think you're going you think
hook doesn't know what piccolo can do oh
yeah mix oh
nice knife
that whipped i'm just gonna get the
re-job wawa just extending your food but
i think you know what piccolo can do but
you're not used to being on the
receiving end of piccolo it's really oh
no no but you age again we're gonna put
a ton of damage on that zebra lee what's
the mix behind goes for the light
grenades okay are we doing the tk
oh nice i think you wanted to play
smartphone with this but didn't have the
right timing on this who tries to go
forward nice reflect yes match the
potatoes
okay
2m grab level one
it's a level one
it's a level one
and while i already bounced his last
character in less than in less than 80
seconds
72 to be exact i could count
count
oh huh yeah string him up oh what you
doing big boy we don't play you this
season big fella oh you got mixing big
dollar fixed you got mixed big fella
oh yeah we are looping you big fella
oh step on them
i like that we kept it meaty
nope we getting out of here
yeah
nope
nope
oh yeah this team is so good and lame
yeah yep no gimmicks here stop it my god
your gimmicks will not work here
all right
i think we're going low hook is out
there right hook is out there right now
oh yeah oh what
bruh i don't know where you're done
you're done
he's pretty good he's pretty good at
this game he's somewhat of a
he's special he is we are we are
witnessing working good
we are witnessing listen i i see that i
see that laser eyes oh yeah starting to
be activated on this look at the pick on
the top left oh yeah look at the um oh
yeah um
it we we we're seeing shades of zombie
hook and listen by all means mentioned
it before hook is one of the most clutch
around but now that puts the question on
the wawa
he's got a billion teams and right now
it's simple the thing with this team is
if you eliminate kojita early he's just
a team yeah you know he's just a normal
team and it's not the best characters
either and stuff uh
cook
destroyed that vegeta oh yeah you don't
even enable wawa
to like run the gimmick
so now who is wawa
about to pick i think it's gonna be
something within gohan
i was telling you i was talking to him
yesterday after he won and i think i
think this was your best team today and
like i mean yesterday i feel that was
this best team and let's see the double
fusion and i don't know what
oh yeah we woke to france's movement
options now
uh huh knock him down
i like that the baghdad should stop the
dbs
uh-huh
wow
oh
and the two three success the manchester
united what a what is it what a good
like special
why is it like this
oh that jumper is so good
oh he's getting
oh he's blocking yeah he's blocking
that's not the hardest of me you need to
lj him nothing happened just yet oh he's
gonna hit the assist oh
mix
it was a mix
oh okay hold up hold up
hold on hold on
hold
nice
all right i like that switching the
zebra
watch out oh my goodness he was
converted
i like that we win
he's not gonna challenge because there's
a sword right
you can't just like throw
[Music]
reflect on your
[Laughter]
for this conversion he's not even
needing any kind of specific combo say
goodbye to bass vegeta say goodbye to
zebraly piccolo
europe
[Applause]
this can't just be swinging man
[Music]
all right all right hold on hold on we
still got we still got hook
oh no oh
all right we jump huh
nice
are we gonna level up
yeah he was a little bit too far away
oh my goodness
oh my goodness
nice there's no right now yes movement
from wawa he knows that the the can't
come any time
all right
all right hook your kill here get my
grenades and all these levels
down to the trash
oh
and we hope i think he's a lot should be
right he's alive one picture yep
up against my setup time
wow
good block
oh my god he was already
oh he's tight infinite pressure
he does not want to be in a block string
situation
look at this
the vanish how much can he do with this
can he even kill i don't think he can
he's just gonna put him down he's gonna
try to paint something okay oh falco
[Applause]
thank you
for the five-member
nine frames thanks yeah thank you who
thought that was a good idea i don't
know
i don't know
i think my next flight is to japan my
next fight is japan i'm not even going
back home to america with the fellas i'm
going right to headquarters going right
to headquarters
i need to i was like he needs more plus
traffic moves
neutral enough this is your fault this
is my you're in america
it's not really what you said it was no
mix
how does a nine frame stay on medium
help you it makes i don't care that's
above they were like oh he probably
needs both are you right thank you
opening gambit
what a great
wow that's it
that's a adam
that's a dead-based vegetable oh my
goodness
losing base vegeta quite early
wawa
making quick work of the first character
but now the huge tale piccolo zebrally
this this is the room this is a real
money maker on hook's team
don't touch us that's a nice counter all
right
all right set up time
oh yeah opening same side yep that works
that that's actually mixed
that even in voice mix i don't care i
don't care what anything you want to say
it's mixed
in the corner
of the side this time no balls though oh
wait hold up we're building it we got
some meter can he kill him
let's head some grenades
so we're going to mix yeah he was
waiting for a road type there oh nice
counter there not gonna get some more
just waiting for the split finger finger
shots
yeah he's forced to block and that's a
dead vegetable all right this is even
match yeah does it even match up right
there perfectly even hook not even
getting hit with his piccolo oh i think
full screen yeah navigating
where are your legs now
where are your legs now vegeta
all right put the orb on them
same side as well so hard to block
oh knock down again oh yeah we are
running you through the loop through the
blender oh you do not want to be in the
vegito blender right now
oh no bro falco
thank you
send one down
[Music]
again more source no pressure
don't touch us
not happening just yet all right coming
in should not try to uh navigate around
without them go hard but watch out oh
the back dash is being caught
all right like that level three get as
much damage as you can on the dell go on
laugh at him
let's see the frenchman oh oh what are
you looking at he's looking
oh that was a good press but not a nice
dashboard that's a that's a nice d
change as well that's really good
the crosstalk is not gonna land who's
escaping right now while we're taking
his time trying to look for his channel
oh my god what are you doing
he knew he knew i was looking for the z
chance and we still got the smart yeah
look at america we're smiling brother
we're smiling it's manifest destiny this
is destiny manifesting itself oh
destiny destiny
destiny
so
i'm doing well right now guys
you're doing better you okay i feel
great
great yeah i feel great for the morale
is going up on your side
yeah absolutely fabulous right now wawa
is out
uh hook's still in
french three players left
hook
gang
god
never never never rule hook out but
hook is too clutch
on twitter twitter and twitch how can
you watch them hookies watch them what
is he gonna do why did they fly him out
he's just been hiding his neck on stream
well guess what
can i speak some more facts quick
acoustics speak so fast i've read people
saying oh who can say i've watched
let me let me let me let me just say the
thing
that list has been closed in may
you know what happened in april what
happened april the first offline in new
york bob's birthday bash
all of the top east coast stones were
there what was grand finals
oh my goodness it was hug and the kill
scene
i wonder why they were gonna pick i
wonder why i mean we'll just beat one
two weeks after we sent the email hey mr
hook and god you're pretty good at this
game would you like to go to france and
represent america i don't want to hear
any of this what talk like come on
purple which could even take one of
wawa's characters
who
which one of y'all cause hook hook took
three
in two batches only fact man all right
only [ __ ] we don't we don't lie
we don't like let's go back to razor
his friends gonna send to try and stop
hook
welcome back to the main stage ladies
and gentlemen on the right side who
again god who just mobs two french
players in a row he got
he got kane unlocked
he just got wawa unlocked
bro it is what it is anyway
yeah sweet speak up speak up
speak up prison
they need to hear you speak up
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry guys
judah what's next uh the next player i
think will be the goat the only one the
second one of the second player
i think i have the most
interesting
achievement
my man
let's go
it's time for the redemption
this is the redemption arc ladies ladies
and gentlemen yasha
stand up boy
on the left side yes on the right side
hook
damascus acoustics
what's up
what's up yeah what's up my friend
what's up buddy
what's good bro may we
all right
so i think it's a very interesting one
we we mentioned earlier that nerves
really play like a lot right now right
now you have hook in the zone hook is
that what he's doing
he's just glowing the ice glowing you
know like he's got
he's at 120 percent of his capacities
right now yeah yashar
lost just the horrible way that's still
in his mind right
and he clearly showed a lot of nerves
nervousness earlier
so that's a huge question yasha can you
overcome your nerves play your game and
try to stop this one
are the players ready
yeah
they're ready you're ready guys right
anyway let's go wait wait wait wait
yeah
say bon appetit
[Laughter]
yes we can
yes we can
let's get it going hook
oh look at that look at him
oh all right i think he's going to be
the main team now yeah oh yeah vegito
basically yes
all right let's see
waiting to see asha's team
hook gang gods carrying the entire yeah
oh look at the population look at this
lego america oh they're afraid now
on his shoulders ah
a chain on them who brought the drip
that's the thing that's touch money and
this is the yashar main feature
right
let's see
one of the portuguese objectives
if he hits you once it's eighty percent
oh yeah it's always right there it's
like it's literally that's that's what
the team is team go ahead
with the opening
now
two and a half meters don't jump
this is the one touch game
if you can get an opening
but hook defense is extremely solid
staggers are there hook is not pressing
any kind of button yet nice yup we
learned that from y'all let's just just
do the work defensively you know you
french guys aren't too bad when you're
teaching us oh nice
luckily he had no he's so happy he
didn't have no spare bomb oh my goodness
oh wow electronic sports he's so big
that's gonna be dropped though
this movement by asha is going to get
caught
by zebra and we're getting oh no oh
we're getting past vegeta there is a
huge uh i don't know this character
they keep changing depending on who is
against
who all right i like that the zoning
from hug all right skill block oh
there's six seven missions
you got away from the fight then oh yeah
we're jumping away we're not right now
make it seven frames
maybe that will hit hook
maybe maybe that would work you're right
you're right
nice block
yes
oh yeah i'm taking this nope where are
you going
that's okay get away yes i supposed to
block right now there's a ton of blue
light on that vegeta side he's forced to
wait and that's gonna be the z challenge
baseball coming in successfully the boys
are fighting each other right now base
goku and piccolo
oh that was good
um
oh last time i saw as many blocks i was
on
we're not in the right game
we're here to press buttons
oh
and that's a dead piccolo okay all right
we have a dead namekian down but we got
two saiyans kings right here on the left
oh my goodness the round start cake
all right still zoning making our way in
oh yeah keep throwing key blast at him
check the plasma
oh yeah yes is that funny no he's too
tiny make him bigger make him bigger
all right nice i like that keep them out
no what a dredge nope what's in your h
oh yeah oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh he's dead he's dead
oh is he yes he's always better that's
sorry i thought he's going to look he's
got
hook super dash again split finger
grab
you mad at me
okay
oh yeah
no he dropped it yeah
we kept it simple you know what i love
it i love it that's the most simple bnb
i haven't seen [ __ ] in a minute you know
why he knows when the nerves are coming
on because he's a professional oh yeah
we have to support
oh don't touch us
and the key that instructor there's
almost in them oh yes
that was an illegal starter that's
definitely oh
yes
get the rejoin oh
that's what we like to see
we like them we take the opportunities
let's go
three hugs yeah do the easiest combos
thank you easiest
all right hold up
all right this is huge favorite but it
looks like oh yes
all right josh is going to wait for this
to come back right now whoa
oh
nice conversion
what's hook's defensive decision right
now
yo press one if you got acoustic did you
get hit first one if you got hit i gotta
hit the overhang
hey
hey
hey hey
the just like
i see the ones
on this day
in paris
we all got hit we all right
all of us
none of us blocked all right oh look at
him taking a deep breath
all right don't worry
or drop it actually i would like you to
drop it okay all right come on down
yeah we learned that from y'all we
learned that from you look at us yep
americans it's good take it for more
better every day
all right putting that
down
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you thank you for telling me
you're the best domestic can you totally
[Music]
the spot oh he had the first but not the
second hook is going to be able to
tackle that deep really out
nice
oh i like the conversion
trying to wait in the corner
right now
i have no use for saying that i can't
fight oh
nice i like the coverage oh great
oh yeah oh great defense great defense
great defense
[Applause]
[Music]
you've got the spark to block right now
there's lots of blue light on your side
let's go good one goes for the simplest
combo yasha don't try anything dragon
rush and that's gonna be
into the level one that is a dead base
vegeta all right this is still piccolo
team broly it can happen to you
it can happen to you
it can it can happen to anyone it can
happen anyway it can happen literally
anyone
it is happening to him right now got to
watch out
can he kill
he's got the assist now
the blocking quarter has been met he's
not blocking anymore he cannot block the
blocking gauge is done wow he's blocked
too much in this game we're pressing
buttons now and yasha
has that piccolo in pretty much one
touch right now considering his team
oh good reflect good reflect oh no
yeah just gonna go for the extension
let's go re-jump yeah don't drop this
re-jump he's there yeah
yeah with a conversion let's go esports
kicks final
candy
[Applause]
all right
hulk is out now
but that was some great work i'm not
gonna lie great stuff from yasha
um
all right i'm making trips to japan i
need to talk to some people about
certain characters
first of all massive performance from
yasha absolutely being able to stop who
was on a roll yep right now right but i
want to say this
and i've said it before i strongly
believe yasha is the most might be the
most underrated player on earth right
now
because
he's not well known outside of his
region and the people in america really
like are actively following
but it's ridiculous have you seen the ex
legs against broly's armor
the conversions the defense he blocked
for 30 seconds straight
have you ever blocked for 30 seconds
straight across six i only did that one
time and then i started the square bond
society
chad have you ever blocked for more than
30 seconds
in your life
i have not
i mean i've tried i get opened up after
10.
of course no everyone says no anyone who
says yes he's capping on the chat
we know it guys who knows guys we know
it yasha
bringing america
to the final hope
but you gotta watch out because we've
seen jonathan tenney
on the previous set
really surprising everyone and he can
definitely still give some surprise i've
made sure when he was winning i went to
the reserve and i threw the kinder bueno
in the bin just do the kinder away we
have we have like we made a mistake we
have a fridge full of kinder there yeah
we made a mistake no no i first need to
know
like it has to be done
we powered him up too much but jonathan
tennant is the final hope
the final hope for america
the west coast champion
he took kaiden down on the previous set
can he take yasha down if he loses
any any game won by france right now on
the first two
he's done it's gg's it's the ends listen
if anything the fact that his first or
two each time is in his favor because
that means at least he can he can afford
one loss per opponent and get himself a
breathing if this was based off of lives
this would be much more scary but
luckily
he resets after each match yeah so
jonathan has a chance
first gotta take down yasha
after yasha is done i don't know who
they're gonna send in but they got two
very strong options
they got kaiden
and then they got kite is durag
those are the very two strong players
over on their side
and you don't know what percentage
kaiden is on you don't know what he's
hiding i don't know the brain in there
like legends has it that when he takes
it out it's actually guinea's brain it's
kind of the brain coming out
i i have personally like no human has
ever seen what's under this drug
but legend has it that is guinea's brain
the brain is popping out of his head yo
just let y'all know how serious that is
mind you we've been at the same hotel
for the last couple of days i have yet
to even get a glimpse of what's under
guidance dude
it's actually od you're gonna do this
and then like
all right spencer are we ready yes i
believe that you're ready jonathan on
the right side yeah this kind of bueno
he's ready i believe the last man
standing for usa so for every american
people on the stream send your energy to
this guy he's gonna try to do the run
back against all of these men we've got
yasha on the left side jila is still
alive and kaiden is still there good
luck to both of them
and ladies and gentlemen
let's get ready to rumble
we got some weird michael buffer bites
we got some original
michael buffer vibes
if you're a fan of any fighting sports
there are two lines you know yeah that's
gonna make it rumble and it's time
to
let you know and you know like he's you
know like uh reza is a huge boxing mma
fan and everything you know so obviously
just one of the greatest that's right
all right
begin acoustics
i'm running out of breath not because
i'm big
because they're taking my breath away
but this level of play from both the
french and the usa player honestly i'm
so
regardless you know results whatever i
am so happy we get to witness high-level
dragon ball fighters offline and it's
only the beginning right the world
championship is starting to stick can we
talk the conversion from 5s from china
to 10a so good
oh the mix that's a giant medium
johnson's gonna get a lot of damage from
this ah one loop uh two loops uh oh yeah
blue
blue blue loop isn't true
yes we thought you know blue is blue in
french blue is what we say to anchorage
french like the french team
oh we respect the blue oh my god again
listen you know what when when the real
champion was nerfed this guy has always
been to him because he didn't do him yep
he said like people forgot but he's
always been the hidden gmc oh nice in
the conversion again jonathan playing
out of his mind
oh what's hoping i guess he was waiting
for yasha to do action after whip and
though
oh
you ever floated into a mix
just get your own dome piece opened up
by yourself
huh nice decent damage from the option
what attack
oh
yes i was not ready for this one he
definitely wasn't yeah oh nice i like
this it's a knock down and finally
jonathan switching out characters that's
i feel like that's by giving his strong
his greatest weakness his entire time
it's just character management yeah like
we've even actually got him out that
happened recently of uh only saving
spark for zebra at the end he's actually
started unsparking a second character
and sometimes even his first wow i love
the reflect on this it's still a risk
because if he doesn't go for the swords
you know you get punished but
that's really worked well forcing him
into the corner
[Music]
[Laughter]
they're not reeling my chest
i was like i got hit i'm not even in the
game
oh nice that was a spare bomb conversion
right there
all right he's too high to get a big
stuff for this yep
[Music]
oh wait watch
oh
[Music]
where to block this one oh there we go
all right we're going left and right
we're having our phone yeah shutting
that 21 down okay
all right 2-2 right now
still possible anyone's game
jonathan having a little bit more health
though
nice
vegito assistance is off the plate oh no
he dropped him he's a little bit too
high for that but he's for the 3d
conversion there
nice dash block
showing us his defense is out there man
look at the delay to get the loop
nice get your knock down
safe jump
oh nice reverse advantage
oh the whip two h
73 frames to confirm 73 ah the lean back
oh we're bringing in the yosha man
my goodness
what a block oh mix oh oh
my goodness
okay
the second one gonna be built he's gonna
get the second bar yeah yeah number one
all right yeah he's just gonna go for
one because he's over here kyle kane is
a huge level one obviously
in the put him in the trash
where he belongs imagine imagine if
you're for another meter you can make
your character get off go who's on just
be like no no
okay it's time for your shot to try and
make the comeback now it's brony with
spark
yep the game starts at win condition
yeah this is the winning initially has
been conditioned as well he's got
baseball and spark this is actually the
start of the game
he's just waiting for baseball to be to
be in limit break yeah you know both of
these are too
he needs vegito to die to do a comeback
oh wow he delayed it
oh yeah he's working
all back the back that was smart oh team
slipped in
level three not gonna kill oh
wow jasha can't spark a few months
no why don't you wait she was waiting
ready for this that was also armored to
make sure he's gonna beat the assist
such a smart choice yeah forgot about
this but watch out vegeta that's that's
what your level juice box although
that's vegeta's part yeah probably get
away really soon all right good now oh
no oh no oh no no oh no
[Applause]
that should have been the patch notes
okay
one france is one game away
from winning
the entire event winning the france
versus usa but i must say jonathan
tenney is doing a ridiculous work so far
trying to get a bit more but right now
forced to block oh no what what he did
oh he got he got saved by the baseball
classic he actually did good job joshua
nice no just to convert
oh yeah
that was a very good thing already
guaranteed the guaranteed way out anyway
from legs so if you guys don't want to
deal with the legs mix you can guard
console and the super dash is going to
open him up nice i like that the ex get
the combo going
all right
and the dr get the sliding knockdown
wow
don't try to touch it that's the thing
why is that like a thing
no
we we've already had dark times with dps
we're not doing this again
we're not doing this again
all right he chooses vegito not the best
uh you know
opening game in the corner but just
wants to lock her into the corner with a
long block string the bass request is
coming back slowly but surely he doesn't
have bars though so look at jordan
six seven six seven minutes that's what
he took
i told people six seven wasn't blocked
but they like they're like cool six the
minute offline's come back people are
just going to block 6am bro
look at this these are some of the best
in the world
and they have been opened up by 6m
[Music]
i'm just saying
i'm just saying
all right
[Music]
all right and jonathan downs his last
two characters ah nice punish that
that's a nice conversion as well it's
gonna get the falling glue yeah oh the
drop is that was unfortunate keeping the
pressure on you dude
so he didn't he didn't like corner
himself yasha did a dash block yeah to
get out of the corner it's an extremely
hard of maneuver to input and the
opening again yasha's movement once
again reigns supreme and there we go
gets the auto combo oh he's gonna stop
he's gonna stop there try and get some
more great tech by jonathan today that
defense is absolutely ridiculous
like defensively jonathan had just been
so on point
oh
nice goodbye
yeah he had the stagger but he did not
commit to anything he committed oh yeah
not using his openings
that's a nice reflect
wow
and jonathan being the turtle but guess
what we're going to crack open this
turtle shell real quick brother
and then i get the patch he did this the
patch he did the patch is winning the
game starts now this is the french patch
we are playing on the french switch the
game starts now acoustics oh yeah about
to try and do the comeback
against that zebra with spark
the wind condition is activated oh nice
all right
all right we're gonna go for the level
three no level three oh try to read the
object
oh yeah
no
my goodness
three
dragon rush putting him into the corner
all right and the next hit will actually
kill wow
wow
all right all right folks
[Music]
the brain is massive ladies and
gentlemen the winner
of that france versus usa
the one and only
[Music]
la frost manga
mary why did he ruin cancer
why did he roam again so this is the
wrong game for that
[Music]
how did he think
i'mma finish the entire event
with a typical yasha play
because this my friend i was showing you
clips of yasha earlier right
every time i watch yasha play
there is a new
out of this world
spark bait
my goodness what
[Applause]
like but it covered so many options too
oh
good good stuff good stuff from joshua
great stuff to kane everyone else that
complete on the french team
jello who competed once as a captain
good stuff
the the mandem take it this time as
tyronn would say
the mandem take it this time
us
we have to try harder wait listen this
acoustics this is the opening event
this is the operative season we
understand the region
let's just the beginning
this you'll be back
i'll be back
and tyrone will be back look at who's
back look who's back don't be back at
the bench turret and jake turrican
jiggly
um
[Music]
yeah the resilience that we were seeing
from the us players in the second set we
really saw hook gang god come alive it
was summit hook that showed up and it
was it was a sight to see and even
jonathan like doing his best to fight
off yasha not able to clinch it out in
the end but
you know great play overall and france
were just the they were the better team
this this time oh can you say this
because
france was stability
all right guys get the camera here so
they can get a clear shot of me saying
y'all better enjoy this
get
[Laughter]
say it
say acoustics
france was a better team
this time
france was better
and they defeated the us
convincingly
what's left to say
that was that was that was the defeated
mei we that i feel the acoustics i
understand but like you said this is
only the beginning
and uh
you know i'm looking for a rematch
that's all i got to say
i was saying this right what i hope
about this because i've seen twitter
i've seen all of you guys on social
media this is only the beginning of the
rivalry yeah because you know what's
going to happen right now mm-hmm
america obviously we're going to
backstage tonight right like today but
people are going to fly back to america
yeah and be like we're coming back and
we're there and the people who have not
been selected for the team are going to
you know the world championship i'm
going to be there i'll be the one to
represent america next time and to take
it yeah
exactly that that's what i want i want i
want sonic fox's flats
oh sorry you know with sage and super
noon oh
to raise the games oh the the sonic
region you know the sonic region
the sonic region
the apartment region to activate
because you know that whenever this
happens again remember regional finals
are offline at the end of the year yeah
in december and then the world finals
the next time we will see francis usa
and japan this time
will be early 2022 and that's what i
want the rivalry is ready but you know
what let's go to reza he's there with
our winners fresa
what do you got for us
i'm here with the american team so first
of all i just want to say
nah that's pretty good i don't like
i don't like the
loser world you know but anyway
thanks to you guys
i don't like the loser words
bro don't laugh man don't vlog it's real
thank you for coming in friends fighting
the french players wawa kaiden yasha
gila and kane
it was great to have you there guys i
wanted to see this offline for my eyes
for a long time we had it today so i'm
gonna give you the microphone so you can
speak for your team first what did you
think about all of that the organization
the flight the tournament and are you
ready to grind back the game for what's
coming next
uh great tournament great experience
yeah the french players definitely have
been grinding and their passion for the
game is definitely admirable um after
talking to them like they they seem kind
of sad that like even i like stop
playing the game they want to play
people at their strongest um
and i feel like we played pretty good
um i'm really happy we got to come out
and play other than the extreme levels
of moisture in the venue it was it was
pretty fun and good
and
uh yeah like i'm really hopeful for the
future of the game i hope people
continue to play it and enjoy it
and
yeah it was
it was a pretty crushing defeat but not
as far
like we're not as far away as i thought
we were after playing for a few days i
would definitely would like to try it
again
in the bronx
[Music]
come to the bronx
that's the message guys
come to the bronx
thank you very much another one maybe
from somebody else from the team
i just want to say hook was kind of
cracked today
so was today they were kind of od
they definitely they definitely proved
why they're here right they definitely
feel right you should be here
cloud i'm sorry it's okay bro look man
this is at the end this is just the
beginning of a story all right
it's the beginning all right it's not
about it's not it's about the journey
dude not the destination destination i
like that i like the journey not the
distinction i like to hear that
maybe hook jonathan
sure yeah
um
i i was i was really excited to come
here because
uh i really i just wanted to play all
the european players and i was it was a
lot of fun
um
i'm sorry that i couldn't like
be as in shape as i wanted to be i felt
like i i wasn't
i wasn't playing as good as i wanted to
which is unfortunate but uh it was a lot
of fun anyway all right thank you bro
hook
maybe
the french players are od hey
[Applause]
um i have over day so being here has
inspired me to become a full-time dragon
ball player again so i'm dropping strive
again
[Music]
yo this is not happening this is not
happening guys
this is not happening
this is not appending guys i'm dropping
nitro i'm dropping stride that game's
garbage it's time to play dragon ball
it's time to play dragon
ball don't
you just killed all of us man i'm sorry
guys
that much keeps me dead there is no more
tournament right
damn okay thank you guys you can go on
the right side with koga
thank you very much guys a round of
applause for the american team
all the rules broken in the spirit of
one minute
what all the rules broken in the street
we just received the paper
it says
you are all cancelled hey hey they took
a piece of my pin
they got the pink slip from my shirt
it's for all of us i don't know it was a
pleasure at the opening and closing
event
[Laughter]
regardless you know like i want to give
i said i want to give a big shout out to
the american players because it's been a
lot of fun you know of course yes
victory for friends but the the sets
were amazing they're super entertaining
hook 108 have really brought the hit
today yeah we really had like some
amazing games and i know that
tonight's the last night for most of the
players though most of us are just going
back home
tomorrow so i know that the session is
going to be absolutely thank you i i
really would like to try and stream this
one but the hotel wi-fi is a bit weird
but i'll do my best you know if i if i
can at least do something that would be
cool but regardless i know that
it's super cool that we got to witness
france's us
i also think the rivalry is on i see the
people in chat i see the people on
twitter
an l
is only temporary
you take else
you get better yeah and eventually
you are handy to w exactly
listen if you take like one l and then
get like the correct angle and add
another
that's a w
that's a w that's a w that's packs
[Applause]
with a french team let's send it back to
rizzo
thank you damascus and the winner of
team is there
what
[Applause]
so
i don't have any question i'm just happy
to see these guys winning this
tournament today because i knew they
were about to win
we've been running the national
championship for seven weeks
we've seen all the gameplays from west
coast east coast spain japan and france
and we knew that the french player were
the best but that's it i'm gonna give
you the microphone guys and you can say
whatever you want in french or in
english we'll start with you yeshua
thank you guys i will not talk like long
thank you for all the support
i'm actually proud that
that
the gameplay that we played today like
kaiden kane ziller
and wawa
we can we can really be proud of
ourselves
will be
and last last word
i actually i actually didn't thought
that
we are we were going to struggle that
much
so american players are super super od
oh let's
um
oh it doesn't need to win a game and the
team is still winning
may uh
[Music]
and we can give a round of applause to
the american player
he was happy to fight this team but he
believes that sonic fox was missing
so one day we'll be there and the team
will be complete the front is ready to
take that challenge
he said one more thing
if any country
want to face the french player japanese
congo canada they're ready for it
thank you kane and one one more thing
for yasha right i want to ask hook i
want to ask a question for you hook
is what was the only problem
he asked if wawa was the only problem
nothing more
look man i was ignorant you know i
didn't know what i was saying you guys
you guys are crazy bro
no
we're playing out there we're playing
man
uh jila is going to be on the bench not
to worry about him so thank you mercedes
[Applause]
thank you guys on the stream chat the
stream is not over i'm going to bring
gila to the bench with jake ryan
damascus acoustics and maybe there is
tyrant i'm not sure about it but let's
go jilla
you missed he's definitely
i got i got one question for jilla
the the two-time champ now
it's a two-time champ that is a great
leadership trait
when can we get our rematch
uh every
when you want when you want okay we love
to fight uh every country actually we
can say we are the best country in the
world actually
besides of the season three and season
four actually we are doing the best best
country uh
by far
by the result
by the result
yeah for sure by far
i'm honest i'm on this did you hear that
tomorrow did you hear that go eat you
cause no no no look at the yes
go ichika you are not ready for us
i was saying after the decision true i
was tweeting i was saying uh it's okay
to lose right now uh i accept the defeat
i was a bit rusty but it's okay
after after the season three i will be
better than the season one in season two
i will be there with some guys in france
and you are not ready for that wow that
is that is a statement to say you said
that you're going to definitely
they're free
and if anyone want to play against us
and show
me show me do just show me your
strengths by uh biogame play and just
defy us and
show us uh by your result if you are if
you are able to to kill us and then i
will say you are better than us
you know prove it
friends friends another world of friends
is number one in the world in dragon
ball fighterz that's all this guy i like
this guy
a winner's mentality
i
all the french players all my all the
community thanks to the all the
community from europe thanks i'm seeing
you all every message i'm trying to read
all your message
wait is for you the victory i was saying
that a few days ago i was thinking to
wade don't worry we win
we will win this and i just
me and the other player just showed how
france is too strong in the drama of
alice wow
confidence ggs
gg is against france thank you so much
it's been ridiculous and taran this is
just opening
opening event that's the name of the
show and of course that is that's the
first one for the season guys we've got
a whole season of tournaments are you
looking forward to the the world
championship yeah for sure actual
actually for sure i'm just waiting the
information and when uh when i got the
information for that i would just train
hard and when i will be under us on a
tournament offline
i won't lose
i like that that's the thing right we're
bringing offline do remember guys we've
announced all the details yesterday
they're all on binance esports twitter
the world championship is opening on
september 18th is going to be from
september to november online events for
all of you guys to rank to get your
ranks and to qualify to offline regional
finals that are in december and then
the top four of each regional finals
will go to
the world finals early 2022 that will
include japan that will include europe
that will link to the us they will
include brazil mexico australia the
middle east and then
by then usa
we'll try to have the revenge but also
japan because let's not forget right of
course we unfortunately due to how the
world works at the moment could not
catch a japanese team to come because
the dream event would have been to get
the japanese team as well there yeah but
you know
all we work on is to make this happen
and the goal is that whenever we get to
that world final
we get the full the actual world to see
who is the best in the world because you
know full well
how japan is you know full well that if
you send the goichis you know the
kazunokos all of these guys no one's
safe listen for all we know it might not
even be one of the regulars you got we
got people who can prove their uh worth
to online points so we might have a
player like big daddy shenron 113
might just come out come out the
woodworks
make something happen you never know
never know that's what we want i have
something else to say uh digital got
mixes
and i'm the vegito owner i'm the vegito
owner since day one digital got mixes
he's definitely top ten gojita four is
definitely top five in the game you
can't be wrong i can't be wrong
uh just show me if i'm wrong but i'm not
wrong i'm always telling it i'm just
always telling the truth
not ready for that
for that message and i have a message
for all the updated just just told me
you're july he's too free
he proved it back july what what have
you seen this weekend i'm free i'm so
free just definitely
i was taking a break for a bit and i was
already 47. that's why i'm just trying
when i want to to fight
against some good players i'm just
training hard to be the best in the in
the world and that's why i'm just
showing my best every time i'm playing
at this game well i'm looking to get the
same energy last the same time but of
course guys we're coming to a close
final jake ryan closing words
i've had a fantastic time with this
event i jilla you are like one of my
favorite players now we have the same
like
you're a king you are straight up a king
he's spitting and you know what the
french the french team while they beat
us i've never seen like such nice people
and you know such a nice place to be so
this community is everything to me i i
love being a part of it and dragon ball
it's only going to get better i'm so
excited the starting on the 18th that's
the best birthday gift i could get
that's perfect that's the best birthday
gift i could get that's all i got
tarrant
just uh thanks everybody for tuning in
and supporting it um and you know like
this is a lot of fun to to put together
with the team and massive shouts to the
consulting team of course for incredible
studio here like they've really put on a
great show with the production the media
everything like that um and they really
looked after the players and the staff
so i can't thank them much more for that
but yeah guys just stick with the with
the world championship and uh look
forward to what you know what's coming
up in the game so yeah absolutely
acoustics closing words
don't don't look at me don't don't leave
don't look at me
don't stop looking at him turn his mind
all right so it's been a great event i
want to thank everybody for being here
french
the
the french the americans
all the other european players
vegeta is a really good character
especially when uh when we just had the
french patch happen recently the french
patch the frenchman the french are just
built differently
they're the patch for the french
difference i want to thank everybody for
coming out i want to thank them for
bringing me here
from new york from the from from the
land of free
all the way out to paris to commentate
for this event it's been great i want to
thank the consultant crew especially uh
davey naomi abu you guys have been like
so friendly you guys are amazing people
should definitely know about the work
you do i got to thank my boy rizza
my man
rizzo light fred
everybody even the dog that was in the
office that you guys didn't get to see
it's it's been a great time here and
with that sound like the masters closes
off all right just to close i'll send it
to race after you know my final words
very simple you know wait
is out there we had so much fun this
weekend i know you guys on the chat had
so much fun with us it's been such a fun
weekend dragon ball is out there the
world championship is going to be kicked
off which means all of the communities
around will have plenty of tournaments i
encourage all of you guys to watch all
of the tournaments around the hoc for
east coast nlbc you've got wednesday
fights on the west you've got plenty of
tournaments in south america you have to
think about my boys in argentina dream
builder who wants plenty of tournaments
you got plenty you know in europe the
galaxy explosion that reza runs the the
online gaming sphere from tyrants and
we've got plenty of tournaments around
in the world do make sure you tune in
follow all of us all of us stream want
to make sure you follow i do weekly
every tuesday you know the best weekly
in the world because like
i stream now monday tuesday and
wednesday so you guys should check me
out on twitch we affiliate now do make
sure you join everyone because dragon
ball is nothing without all of you guys
we have fun but you guys are the fun one
thank you so much for everyone for
joining us for the opening event dragon
ball fighterz is kicking off a new
season of competition let's send it away
to raza to close the event
we miss you you've said it all man
you've said it all
but i'm going to start with a little run
guys don't be afraid to play dragon ball
fighters i've seen a lot of people that
don't want to play and try the game
because they're afraid to fight these
guys this monster because they've got
three thousand hours of the game four
thousand hours of the game you don't
care just play the game if you enjoy the
game try to become better and try to
get in those tournaments online or fly i
don't know at least play dragon ball
fighterz i want to say thank you to
everybody in this room thanks to the
caster i met some good guys from america
jacqueline acoustic today uh thank you
to end cover bandai
trisha japan thank you to everybody who
made this event possible and thanks to
you on the chat on the chat guys it's
nothing there is no disrespect it's just
a great rivalries between friends and
usa and it's gonna get good cause sonic
fox is coming back soon i believe so
thank you guys and don't forget play
dragon ball fighterz let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]